GOOD MR MAYES GOOD MORNING MR
CHAN. I'M THINKING IN THE
INTERESTS OF- EXPEDIENCY THAT I
WILL PRESENT MY BILL NOW. EVEN
THOUGH WE'RE OPERATING AS A SUB
COMMITTEE- THAT WAY YEAH. I CAN
TAKE BACK THE GAVEL AND WE CAN
GET ON WITH THINGS. ONCE WE HAVE
A QUORUM. ALL RIGHTY SO MR MAYS
I'M GONNA PRESENT MY- LONELY
BILL. AND. FIVE PLEASE DO IT
FROM FROM HERE. YEAH I'LL DO IT
FROM HERE. I WAS JUST REALLY
JUST FOR THE RECORD- IN IT
BEFORE SKEWS ME MR MAYES-
THEREFORE CONSENT CALENDAR BILLS
TODAY- BUT WE'LL GET INTO THAT
AFTER A ONCE WE HAVE. MORE FOLKS
HERE ABOUT SEVENTEEN COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HAPPENING
SIMULTANEOUSLY- HOUSING IS
DOWNSTAIRS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
HAPPENING. SO THE PERSON'S NEXT
DOOR WE'LL WE'LL GET A COUPLE
MEMBERS ONCE ONCE THE PURSE
COMMITTEE IS FINISHED. SO MY
BILL AB TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY.
ADDRESSES THE- DEBT IN OUR
STATE'S UNEMPLOYMENT FUND. THE
BILL PROPOSES TO MAKE A ONE TIME
INVESTMENT OF SEVEN POINT TWO
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS TOWARD THE
TWENTY BILLION DOLLAR. OUT
STANDING DEBT. THE INVESTMENT
WILL SIGNIFICANTLY DECREASE THE
TOTAL INTEREST OWED ON THIS DEBT
EASING THE BURDEN ON BUSINESSES
AND SUPPORTING THE STATE'S
FISCAL STABILITY. THE COST OF
PAYING FOR THAT DEBT WILL HIT
SMALL AND LARGE BUSINESSES ALIKE. NEXT YEAR EVERY EMPLOYER IN
CALIFORNIA WILL PAY TWENTY ONE
DOLLARS MORE PER EMPLOYEE. AND
THAT NUMBER WILL DOUBLE. THE
FOLLOWING YEAR. AND CONTINUE AT
FORTY TWO DOLLARS PER EMPLOYEE
UNTIL THE DEBT IS REPAID.
BUSINESSES PAY THE PRINCIPAL ON
THIS DEBT. THE STATE PAYS THE
INTEREST ON THE DEBT. SO WITH
THE WITH THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
SURPLUS I THINK IT'S A PRUDENT
INVESTMENT TO USE SOME OF THE
SURPLUS TO PAY DOWN THAT DEBT-
MR MOULTRIE IS HERE FROM THE-
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE. AGAIN
WE'RE OPERATING AS A SUB
COMMITTEE THERE WON'T BE A VOTE
ON THIS BILL YET I JUST WANTED
TO. MOVE FORWARD WITH OUR AGENDA
SO GO AHEAD MR MOULTRIE. THANK
YOU MR- THAT MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE ROBERT MUTRIE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
REYES SPONSOR AND STRONGLY
SUPPORTED B. TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTY- ACELERA DALY APTLY
TOUCHED ON THE FINANCIAL
CONCERNS FOR THE STATE AND FOR
THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY I'D LIKE
TO JUST HIGHLIGHT A FEW POINTS
BRIEFLY. FIRST SON INCLEMENT
INTEREST TAX INCREASE THAT'S
COMING NEXT YEAR WILL HIT SOME
OF THE HARDEST HIT SECTORS AND
THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY I'M FROM
CALVET LIKE RESTAURANTS AND
OTHERS FOR REALLY MANPOWER
INTENSIVE AND WILL SEE THE
HIGHEST TAX INCREASES AS A
RESULT. I DON'T LIKE THE FLAG.
ALL SHE POINTS IT THE MIND OF
LEGISLATURE FIRST- WE ARE
PRESENTLY WORKING AND IF SPOKEN
ALLEGE COUNCIL TO TRY TO FIND
WAYS TO HELP ADDRESS NOT JUST A
THE OVERALL INSOLVENCY BUT THE
TAX INCREASES ANTICIPATED NEXT
YEAR DIRECTLY FOR WORKING ON
SOLUTIONS IN THAT DIRECTION WITH
THIS BILL. I ALSO LIKE THE FLAG
IN AGAIN LIMIT IS ON EVERYONE'S
MIND- AS THE L. L. CORRECTLY
NOTED THERE FEBRUARY TWENTY
SECOND PUBLICATION ON THE STATE
APPROPRIATIONS LIMIT WE DO
BELIEVE MONEY SPENT THIS WAY CAN
HELP ADDRESS THOSE PROBLEMS
WHICH ARE AN OVERALL BUDGET
CONCERN FOR LEGISLATORS. IN THE
INTEREST OF GRAVITY- I'LL AND
THEY'RE NEEDED URGENT I THOUGHT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU- JUST AS A
REMINDER WE ARE ON- AB TWENTY
FIVE SEVENTY- AND THE CHAIR IS
PRESENTING- FROM THE DYESS- BUT
WE'RE GONNA MOVE- TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION NOT SEEING ANY. OR IS
THERE SOME OPPOSITION. YES WE DO
HAVE SOME OPPOSITION. BUT I
REQUEST FOR ALL THE SUPPORT. YEP
THAT'S OKAY WE'LL WE'LL DO THAT
THE TESTIMONY THAT WILL POP
EVERYBODY CONSISTENT. THANK
MISTER CHAIRMAN MITCHELL WITH
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL MANY APOLOGIES FOR THE
LATENESS OF OUR OPPOSITION AND
FOR NOT HAVING A LETTER AND BUT
WE DO HAVE PRETTY FUNDAMENTAL
OBJECTIONS TO NOT JUST.
ESSENTIALLY PUTTING TAXPAYERS ON
THE HOOK FOR EMPLOYER
RESPONSIBILITY BUT ALSO I THINK
MORE TO THE POINT THAT WHILE
KOBE DEFINITELY PLAYED A ROLE IN
THE SIZE OF THIS DEBT THE
FUNDAMENTAL PROBLEM HERE'S THE
INSOLVENCY OF OUR SYSTEM. AND IF
IT IS NOT COVERED IT'S A
RECESSION IT'S ANY NUMBER OF
OTHER THINGS WAITING IN THE
WINGS THAT COULD CAUSE US TO
GENERATE ANOTHER MASSIVE DEBT TO
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THAT
WOULD THEN NEED A MASSIVE
INTEREST PAYMENT FROM THE STATE.
WE STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT ANY
SORT OF BAIL OUT OF THIS SIZE
SHOULD DEFINITELY COME WITH THE
FUNDAMENTAL RESTRUCTURING OF THE
SYSTEM TO PREVENT THIS SORT OF
THAT FROM BEING GENERATED IN
FUTURE WE ALSO THINK THAT IT
ALWAYS NEEDS TO BE MENTIONED
THAT BENEFIT LEVELS IN THE STATE
ARE WILDLY INADEQUATE THE RIGHT.
NOT FOUR HUNDRED FOR MAXIMUM
BENEFIT AMOUNT HAS BEEN IN PLACE
FOR EIGHTEEN YEARS. 40% OF
WORKERS HIT THAT MAXIMUM CAP AND
AS A PAINT AWARE FOUR HUNDRED
FIFTY DOLLARS A WEEK IS NOT
NEARLY ENOUGH TO FUND EVEN YOUR
HOUSING RESPONSIBILITIES AND THE
STATE MUCH LESS EVERYTHING ELSE
THAT YOU NEED TO PAY FOR AS A
CITIZEN OF THE STATE. AND SO WE
REALLY BELIEVE THAT ANY SORT OF
A LOT OF THE SITE SHOULD COME
WITH AN INCREASE IN BENEFIT
LEVELS FOR WORKERS- A REFORM
FUNDING STRUCTURE SO THAT WERE
BETTER ABLE TO WITHSTAND
WHATEVER RECESSIONS ARE COMING
IN THE FUTURE. AND ALSO SOME
SORT OF A SOLVENCY SURCHARGE
THAT OTHER STATES HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THAT IF WE DO NEED TO PAY
OFF INTEREST ON A FEDERAL LOAN
THAT THE SYSTEM ITSELF PAYS FOR
THAT THE EMPLOYERS PAY FOR THAT.
RATHER THAN HAVING TO GO BACK TO
TAXPAYERS TO COVER THAT
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THOSE REASONS
WERE IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
AND- WITH THAT. WE WILL MOVE TO
ALL OF THE ADD ONS- AND MY GUESS
IS MOST OF THIS IS SUPPORT BUT
WILL DO BOTH SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION WITH THE- ADD ONS. AT
THE- AT THE SAME TIME- JUST AS A
REMINDER JUST YOUR NAME AND-
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR CHRIS
MCKINLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
HOLLYWOOD CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTY. THANK YOU. CODYBOILS
IN BEHALF AMERICANS STATURE
GROWERS IN FAR WEST EQUIPMENT
DEALERS- IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ARMAND FELICIANO ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA HOLD
HOTEL LODGING ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
DENISOV YANNI ON BEHALF OF THE
FAMILY BUSINESS ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA WE SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING SABRINA
LOCKHART ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRACTION SOME PARKS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MORNING
WHERE A TOP ON BEHALF OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY BUSINESS COUNCIL
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU KEVIN
PADRONE ON BEHALF OF AND IF I'D
BE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH- AND I'VE JUST BEEN
INFORMED THAT WE ARE NOT GOING
TO THE PHONE LINES IF YOU CAN
SEE THE SMILE ON MY FACE YOUR
SOME OF YOUR UNDERSTAND.
UNDERSTAND WHY. WE CHAD YOU'RE
WELCOME. WITHOUT BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE ACTUALLY WE
HAVE A QUORUM I GUESS WE DO HAVE
A POINT NO NOT YET. NOT YET DO
NEED TO- IT WOULD NEED OKAY- WE
NEED TO MORE TO OKAY GOT IT
WE'RE GETTING WE'RE GETTING
CLOSE BUT WE'LL COME BACK TO
COMMITTEE FOR ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS- MISTER
GIBSON THANK YOU VERY MUCH- I
THINK FIRST VICE OUR SUPPORT THE
BILL BECAUSE- AND WANT TO GO ON
RECORD SUPPORTING TWENTY FIVE
SEVEN THANK THE OFFICE FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL. FORWARD BUT
I ALSO THINK THAT WE SHOULD LOOK
AT WHAT THE- LABOR FAIR HAD JUST
MADE MENTION OF IN TERMS OF
LEASE PUTTING A PLAN IN PLACE-
FOR FUTURE SITUATIONS MOVING
FORWARD SO I JUST WANT TO THROW
THAT OUT THERE THAT WE SHOULD
LOOK AT BECAUSE I DON'T THINK
THIS IS GOING TO LAST TIME- IN
OUR HISTORY THAT WE HAVE THESE
KINDS OF ISSUES THAT- HIT US-
WEATHERS RECESSION WEATHERS A
PANDEMIC. SHOULD LOOK AT A PLAN
THAT WE CAN EXECUTE- IF IN FACT
AND WHEN IN FACT SOMETHING LIKE
THIS HAPPENS MOVING FORWARD SO-
I THINK SAYS THAT WE SHOULD.
START OF CONDUCT THOSE KIND OF
CONVERSATIONS MOVING FORCE I
JUST WANTED TO SAY THAT THANK
YOU. TO YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. SEEING NONE OF WHAT WE
WILL HOLD ON TO THIS- AND WHEN
WE GET A QUORUM- THEN WE WILL
SEEK A MOTION- BUT THANK YOU-
FOR THE WITNESSES AND I THINK WE
NEED ONE MORE MEMBER FOR WE CAN
DO THAT ON A PASS IT BACK TO THE
CHAIR. THANK YOU MISTER MAYES
FOR A- YOU'RE ADEPT HANDLING OF
THE- SUBCOMMITTEE WELCOME MR
VOEPEL WE ARE ONE SHY OF A
QUORUM- WE DO WITH IT WITH WITH
MR CHOI HERE WE HAVE AUTHORS TO
PRESENT- AND THEN WE HAVE MISTER
JONES SAWYER GO AHEAD MR CHOI.
WITH YOUR BILL. THANK YOU CHAU
TOM DALY AND ALL THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE I'M SO PLEASED TO
PRESENT. THE HOT MIGHT BE A LOT
A. B. FIFTY NINETY SIX OF WHICH
IS- IN THE SAME VEIN ABOUT THE
SAME DIFFERENCE ARE SAYING BUT
THE DIFFERENCE IS SELDOM ON UP
THE MONEY THAT THE WE ARE
PROPOSING. AB OF FIFTEEN NINETY
SIX. WILL TO PROTECT THE OLDER
CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES SO FROM ON
ON EMPLOYMENT INSURANCE A TAX
INCREASE SO BY FULLY REPAYING
THE EXISTING UNEMPLOYMENT.
INSURANCE TO DEATH. WITH DST SO
HISTORIC UP BUDGET SURPLUS.
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYERS ESPECIALLY
SMALL BUSINESSES- HAVE A
STRUGGLE TO SURVIVE WELL OVER
TWO. YEARS SO OF THE ONGOING
COVERT NINETEEN CONDEMN IT. HOW
FRIENDLY THE FULL STUFF THIS SO
TOOK ROASTED THE AT THE SOME SO
OCT. SO WERE FORCED TO FLY
UNEMPLOYMENT THE INSURANCE A
CLAIM SO WHICH RAPIDLY- WE
THOUGHT THE PLEADED CALIFORNIA
SO ON EMPLOYMENT INSURANCE FUND
CHORE ADDRESS ONE OF. THIS LAB.
A TO BORROW A OF ABOUT SO FOR
THE FED'S GOVERNMENT THE- IF WE
DO NOTHING- CALIFORNIA EMPLOYERS
SO WILL BE HELPED OUT WITH THE
NEW ANNUAL TAX UP TO REPAY THIS
. UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE ALONE
THAT UP- BEGINNING JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. AB OUT
FIFTEEN NINETY SIX- DIRECTS THE
NINETEEN POINT THREE BILLION
DOLLARS SELF FROM THE ESTIMATED
A FORTY FIVE. TO AN ESTIMATED
SIXTY BILLION DOLLARS UP A
HISTORIC A STATE SO SURPLUS OF
TWO. TWO FULLY REPAID THIS OF
FEDERAL- YOU AYE UNEMPLOYMENT
TECHNICIANS THE LOAN AND THE
PREVENT THAT THIS A TAX INCREASE
UP NEXT YEAR ALSO THE AMOUNT OF-
GERMAN TOM DALY SO MONTEL WAS
SAW- SEVEN POINT THE TOOL BAR.
AB TWENTY FIVE BUCKS A SEVENTY
S. A SEVEN POINT OH TWO BILLION
DOLLARS UP THERE SAYS SAW MUCH
LESS ARE LESS THAN. HALF OF MY
PROPOSAL WHY LEAVE OUT TO MY S.
MONEY SO WHY LEAVE THAT THAT THE
WHEN WE HAVE A- SURPLUS MONEY I
THINK THAT THIS IS A PRUDENT WAY
TO PROTECT THE BUSINESS OF
PEOPLE. AS OF NOW WILL
CALIFORNIA- SO PROXIMITY- NINE
TEN POINT SEVEN BILLION UP TO
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT- IN MY
BID UP. IF MIGHT BE A LOT
BECOMES LAW THIS ALLOWS-
DIRECTOR ABOUT FINANCE SO TO
AUGMENT THE AMOUNT THE
APPROPRIATE ENOUGH FOR THE A
PURPOSE ABOVE FOR REPAYING THE
STATE STATE THAT. OUR OUR
BUSINESSES SUCH SHOULD NOT BE
PUNISHED THOUGH WITH THE NEW
TAXES TO REPAY THE MASSIVE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE CLAIM SO
WHICH WERE THE RESULT OF A
GOVERNMENT THAT IMPOSED A LACK.
LOCK DOWN SOME. I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK A- MISTER RAJI ARE ASKING
ME AS A FRIEND SAYS LOWER. OF
OUT WITH THE CHILD FIFTY ALIAH
WILL BE HERE THIS TO TESTIFY IN
THE THANK YOU TO AND THE MEMBERS
AND- PLEASE ALLOW IT TO THE TEST
THE TEST THE SUPPORT TESTIMONY
IS SO. TO START. BOSSY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU ACT
HONORABLE COMMITTEE MEMBERS TALK
TO TROY THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
HAVING US HERE AND- ALLOWING US
TO BE HERE- MY NAME IS ROSY
HOUSE THE I'M I'M CEO OF JOY
YOGA- CEO'S REALLY A FANCY WORD
ON THE I'M NOT A CO I AM HAD I-
I YOU KNOW I'M A JANITOR ON TECH
SUPPORT I DO SPREADSHEETS SIDE I
DO PRETTY MUCH ANYTHING AND
EVERYTHING FOR THOSE OF YOU THAT
OWN SMALL BUSINESSES- YOU KNOW
WHAT THAT'S LIKE- SO IT'S- WE
YOU KNOW CO JUST A FANCY WORD
BUT I WITH MY WIFE AND I OWN A
SMALL BUSINESS AND- THE BAY
AREA. TRAY OKAY WE'LL THREE YOGA
STUDIOS WITH THE FITNESS PALADE
CYCLEBAR- WE EMPLOY ABOUT SIXTY
FITNESS INSTRUCTORS TWENTY FRONT
DESK STAFF SO I GREW THE
OPERATION AND INVESTED IN
OURSELVES WITH OUR BLOOD SWEAT
AND TEARS THAT GOT. HE EXPECTS
OF THOSE OF YOU THAT ARE DISPLAY
COME COME BY. REFUSING RULES
S. SORRY OKAY I'M HERE I'M I'M
HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF AB
FIFTEEN NINETY SIX WHICH WOULD
PAY BACK THE FULL AMOUNT OF
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE LOANS- TO
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SMALL
BUSINESSES LIKE CHOI YOGA NEED
THE STATE'S SUPPORT NOW AS WE
TRY TO RECOVER FROM THE
DEVASTATING EFFECTS OF THE
EQUIPMENT NINETEEN PANDEMIC
FITNESS CENTERS LIKEMY OWN-
WERE FORCED TO CONTEND WITH ON
AND OFF SHUT DOWNS WHICH
DECIMATED SMALL FITNESS CENTERS
ESPECIALLY IN ALAMEDA COUNTY-
ITS ACT IT WASN'T ON OFFER WAS
PRETTY MUCH THE WHOLE NINETEEN
MONTHS OF- OF SHUT DOWNS THAT WE
HAVE TO CONTEND WITH- AT THE
ONSET OF THE PANDEMIC WE HAD
STOPPED PULLING OUT WORKERS A
JOY BECAUSE WE HAD TO SHUT DOWN
OUR BUSINESS COMPLETELY AND ONLY
ONE OF THE CENTER IS ONE OF ONLY
ONE OF OUR STUDIOS CAN OPERATE
OUTDOORS. WHICH WAS THE ONLY WAY
WE COULD KEEP OUR BUSINESS IS
GOING WE LOST 4250% OF OUR
EMPLOYEE WORK FORCE A JOY
BECAUSE OUR EMPLOYEES WOULD NOT
AFFORD TO- TO GO OUT MONTHS AND
MONTHS OF ON LOST INCOME AND
EVEN THOUGH WE QUALIFIED FOR PPP
LOANS CHOI X. WOULD NOT GET THE
LOAN FORGIVEN BECAUSE WE DID NOT
HAVE THE PAYROLL TO JUSTIFY IT
YOU KNOW THEY GAVE US THE MONEY
BUT THEY KEPT THEY KEPT THE
SHUTDOWN SO WHAT POINT IS AT
WHAT POINT IS IT FOR ME TO TAKE
THE MONEY IF I CAN'T REPAY IT
BACK. TO TOP IT OFF CHOI ALSO
LOST ABOUT 70% OF OUR MEMBERSHIP
BASE THROUGHOUT THE WHOLE
PANDEMIC WHICH WERE AND THEN AND
WHEN WE RE OPENED- AND GOT OUR
BUSINESSES GOING AGAIN- WE WERE
HIT BY OUR LANDLORDS WITH THAT
YOU KNOW THE DEFERRED RENT WHICH
WE WHICH WEST DEFERRED DURING
THE SHUTDOWN WHAT WE'RE DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO BOUNCE BACK
FROM THE PANDEMIC WE CAN'T
AFFORD THESE MONTHS OF SET BACK
AS A SMALL BUSINESS OWNER I
CAN'T STRESS HOW MUCH AB FIFTEEN
NINETY SIX IF NEEDED TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S SMALL BUSINESSES.
FROM YET ANOTHER UNNECESSARY TAX
INCREASE ESPECIALLY WHEN THE
STATE HAS THE ABILITY TO PAY THE
UNEMPLOYMENT THAT BACK
COMPLETELY SMALL BUSINESSES ARE
THE BEDROCK OF OUR COMMUNITY OF
ARC OF OUR ECONOMY AND OUR
FITNESS CENTER SERVED AN
ESSENTIAL ROLE IN CARING DILLON
PHYSICAL HEALTH NEEDS OF OUR
COMMUNITIES SO MANY OF OUR
MEMBERS LOOK TO US FOR RELIEF AS
A RELIEF CENTER BECAUSE WE
PROVIDE THEM WITH AN ESCAPE TO
RELIEVE THE CONSTANCE ACOSTA.
STRESSORS OF THE DAILY LIFE WE
WERE NOT UNABLE TO DEAL. YOU
HAVE A AT A TWO MINUTE TIME
LIMIT ON I THINK. YOU'RE OVER
THAT NOW SO IF YOU COULD WRAP IT
UP PLEASE WILL DO SO I JUST
WANTED TO THANK YOU GUYS SO MUCH
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY I THINK- IF
FOR THIS I URGE. ALL OF US TO
VOTE I ON FIFTEEN NINETY SIX AND
HOPE THAT THE COMMITTEE WILL
PROTECT OUR SMALL BUSINESSES
DURING THE ONGOING. ECONOMIC
RECOVERY CAN'T AFFORD ANOTHER
TAX HIKE SPECIALLY UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY SIR THANK YOU. AND
IT'S YOU YOU'RE IN. A GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I'M FRANCESCA SCHULER I
AM THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA FITNESS ALLIANCE. I'M
HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF AB
FIFTEEN NINETY SIX WHICH WOULD
PAY BACK THE FULL AMOUNT OF THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE LOANS- TO
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. I WANT
TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER STEVEN
CHOI. FOR AUTHORING THIS BILL-BECAUSE OUR SMALL BUSINESSES
WHICH MOST FITNESS BUSINESSES
ARE SMALL BUSINESSES- NEED OUR
SUPPORT AT THIS CRITICAL. TIME
OF ECONOMIC RECOVERY. THE
CALIFORNIA FITNESS ALLIANCE
MISSION IS SIMPLE IT'S TO
PROMOTE A HEALTHY AND FIT
CALIFORNIA. AS THE UNITED VOICE
OF ALL THE FITNESS PROFESSIONALS
IN CALIFORNIA. THE CFA IS MADE
UP OF THREE HUNDRED FORTY FIVE
PARTNER ORGANIZATIONS. AND OVER
THREE THOUSAND FITNESS CENTERS.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY OUR
PARTNERS AND BRANDS EMPLOYED
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS MANY OF THEM SINGLE
PARENTS- AND PEOPLE WITHOUT
COLLEGE DEGREES WHO CAN'T FIND
EMPLOYMENT AT. ANYWHERE ELSE.
WHO ARE ALL COMMITTED TO
PROVIDING SAFE PHYSICAL AND
MENTAL HEALTH OUTLETS FOR
MILLIONS EACH YEAR. BUT OUR
FITNESS CENTERS CANNOT AFFORD
ANOTHER TAX HIKE WHEN WE ARE
STILL REELING FROM THE EFFECTS
OF COVERT FOR THOSE THAT DON'T
KNOW THE FITNESS INDUSTRY WAS
ONE OF THE- ONLY INDUSTRIES THAT
RECEIVED NO DIRECT RELIEF
NATIONAL OR STATE. DURING THE
PANDEMIC WE DID NOT QUALIFY FOR
MOST OF THE RELIEF EFFORTS THAT
WERE GIVEN TO RESTAURANTS AND
OTHER. BUSINESSES FITNESS DID
NOT GET THAT. AS A RESULT IN
CALIFORNIA- WE'RE ESTIMATING
ANYWHERE FROM 35240% OF ALL
FITNESS CENTERS ARE CAN BE
PERMANENTLY CLOSED. FOR THOSE OF
YOU WORK OUT MAY VERY WELL LIKE
WE HAVE A LOCAL FITNESS CENTER
THAT WILL NOT REOPEN. ON THE
FLIP SIDE THOSE THAT ARE LUCKY
ENOUGH TO SURVIVE THEY'RE STILL
BUILDING BACK TO BUSINESS PAYING
DOUBLE RENT WITH THE FOR GRANT
XCERRA. SO JUST TRYING TO SERVE
THEIR COMMUNITIES TO BE HEALTHY.
AND PROVIDE A SAFE PLACE TO
EXERCISE FOR MANY WHO CAN'T
AFFORD HOME GYMS OR THINGS LIKE
THAT. THE FITNESS CENTERS AND
BUSINESSES STATEWIDE SHOULD NOT
BE FORCED TO BEAR YET ANOTHER
ECONOMIC BURDENS. CORNER
ESPECIALLY WHEN THE STATE CAN
TAKE LEGISLATIVE ACTION REPLACE
REPAY ITS UNEMPLOYMENT LOANS.
WITH AB FIFTEEN NINETY SIX THE
STATE WOULD APPROPRIATE OVER
NINETEEN BILLION FROM THE
GENERAL FUND TO THE EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT SO THE
STATE WOULD PAY OFF ALL OF ITS
ADVANCES FROM THE FEDERAL
UNEMPLOYMENT ACCOUNT- I NEED YOU
TO WRAP UP PLEASE THAT'S THE
WORRIES THANK YOU- AND SO GIVEN
THE STATE'S BUDGET SURPLUS THE
STATE HAS AN OPPORTUNITY REDUCES
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE AND
REALLY SHIELD. SO MANY OF THE
SMALL BUSINESSES THAT ARE STILL
TRYING TO RECOVER AND BRING BACK
THEIR EMPLOYEES. WHO HAVE
CURRENTLY NOT BEEN ABLE TO GET
BACK TO WORK FOR THESE REASONS
THE CFA IS PLEASED TO SUPPORT AB
FIFTEEN NINETY SIX. AND ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. I'M
SORRY. WE TOOK A WHEN YOU DO
STABBED QUORUM THAT'S WHY I WAS
GETTING A LITTLE JUMPY. BECAUSE
IT'S A PRECIOUS THING TO HAVE A
QUORUM THAT WAY WE CAN VOTE-
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY AND
LET'S ESTABLISH THE QUORUM NOW
PLEASE. DALY HERE DALY HERE
MAYES HERE MAYES HERE BERMAN.
BIGELOW CALDERON. CALDERON HERE
CERVANTES. CHAN CHAN HERE
CRISTINA GARCIA. COOPER GIPSON
GIPSON HERE GRAYSON. GRAYSON
HERE RODRIGUEZ VOEPEL. VOEPEL
HERE WOULD. WOULD HERE. ALL
RIGHT WE HAVE A QUORUM AND- WANT
TO REMIND THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS-
THANK YOU FOR THE MOTION MR
CHAN- THIS BILL HAS A DOES NOT
HAVE ANY RECOMMENDATION FROM THE
CHAIR THIS BILL DOES NOT HAVE
ONE NOR DOES AB TWENTY THREE
TWENTY THREE BY MR LEVINE- THERE
ON THE AGENDA AS A COURTESY BUT
THERE IS NO RECOMMENDATION FROM
THE CHAIR- MR CHOI DR CHOI.
WOULD YOU- WELL FIRST LET'S
INVITE ANY SUPPORT OTHER
SUPPORTERS TO SPEAK. PRINT
WRITING SUPPORT. COMMENT REALLY
JUST TO NAME IN. SO THANK YOU
KNOW YOU WANT YOU UNDERSTAND
HAVE BEEN HERE BEFORE THEN A
SELFIE ON A HALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FAMILY BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION WE SUPPORT AB FIFTY
NINETY SIX THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE HERE TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR OF THE BILL. ARE THERE ANY
PERSONS HERE. OPPOSED TO THE
BILL. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MITCH SNIDER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL FOR ALL THE REASONS STATED
ON THE PREVIOUS BILL WE WON'T
RESTATE ALL OF THOSE WE WERE
JUST REALLY EMPHASIZE THAT. IN
OTHER STATES WITH A MORE FORWARD
FUNDED YOU AYE SYSTEM NOT ONLY
WILL THEY NOT BE FACING TAX
INCREASES IN COMING YEARS SOME
OF EVEN CUT TAXES WASHINGTON
STATE WHERE I'M FROM. DID CUT
THEIR EMPLOYER TAXES DURING THE
PANDEMIC WHILE ALSO INCREASING
THE MINIMUM BENEFIT FROM TWO
HUNDRED AND TEN DOLLARS A WEEK
TO TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY DOLLARS A
WEEK. OUR MINIMUM BENEFIT IS
FORTY DOLLARS A WEEK SO THERE
ARE A LOT OF ISSUES WITH ARE YOU
AYE SYSTEM AND WE REALLY THINK
THAT. LOST IN THE CONVERSATION
OF HOW BEST TO DEAL WITH THE
LOOMING TAX INCREASES THAT
EMPLOYERS ARE FACING IS THE FACT
THAT WE ARE IN DIRE NEED OF A
FUNDAMENTAL OVERHAUL OF OUR
SYSTEM THAT. NOT ONLY PREVENTS
THINGS LIKE TAX INCREASES
HAPPENING DURING TOUGH ECONOMIC
TIMES BUT ALSO RAISES BENEFITS
FOR WORKERS AND ALLOWS. THE
STATE TO RELIEVE ITSELF OF THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO PAY FOR THE
INTEREST ON THE FEDERAL LOANS
PUT THAT RESPONSIBILITY BACK
INTO THE SYSTEM WHERE IT WHERE
IT BELONGS WE ARE JOB POSITION.
THANK YOU MR STEIGER ANY OTHER
PERSONS WISHING TO SPEAK AGAINST
THIS BILL. IF NOT- DOCTOR CHOI
THIS IS YOUR OPPORTUNITY TO.
WRAP UP OKAY- ONCE AGAIN THE-
THANK YOU UP TO A TESTIFIED YES
OVERSEE AND THE PROCESS OF
FRANCESCA ACCORDING TO A RECENT
THE L. A. O. A REPORT THAT THE
U. I. LONA AND THE ASSOCIATED
ENTRESTO ORDER LIKELY TAKE
APPROXIMATELY A TEN YEAR SET TO
REPAY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. I
DO HAVE- THOSE BORDERS- OTHER
THAN CALIFORNIA FITNESS OUT ALLY
UNISA- THEY ARE A CALIFORNIA
ASIAN CHAMBER OF COMMERCE-
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION
COALITION ABOUT SMALL AND THE
DISABLED VETERANS- BUSINESSES-
AND THE NATIONAL FEDERATION OF
INDEPENDENT BUSINESSES OUR
BUSINESSES ARE STRUGGLING TO
STAY AFLOAT AND THAT THERE WERE
A SOME BUSINESSES SAID THAT
WOULD NEVER FINANCIALLY RECOVER
I RESPECTFULLY. ASK WE ARE ABLE
. THANK YOU DR THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THERE ANY. SO OF THE
AUTHOR. I'M NOT SEEING ANY
QUESTIONS- WE DID OF MISTER
GIBSON GO HEAD SURE TO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH DOCTOR CHOI FOR
BRINGING US BEFORE US SO IS IT
YOUR UNDERSTANDING THAT YOU WANT
TO TAKE. BOB THE HOLDEN NOT
NINETEEN POINT SEVEN. BILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE- BUDGET SURPLUS
AND APPLY TO THE FEDERAL DEBT
THAT WE OWE. THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. YES OKAY A CEMEX
ROUND. CLEAR THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER GIBSON ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS- WE HAD A
MOTION I BELIEVE. BY MISTER CHAN
AND A SECOND FOR MR VOEPEL ANY
OTHER COMMENTS- IF NOT LET'S GO
AHEAD AND VOTE AND AGAIN THIS SO
THERE'S NO RECOMMENDATION ON
THIS BILL. FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR
EIGHTY FIFTEEN NINETY SIX MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
DALY ABSTAINED DALY OBTAINED
MAYES HI MAYES I BERMAN. BIGELOW
CALDERON. CALDERON NOT VOTING
CERVANTES CERVANTES NOT VOTING
CHEN. COOLEY I'M SORRY CRISTINA
GARCIA COOPER GIPSON IF THE NOT
VOTING GRAYSON. GRAYSON NOT
VOTING RODRIGUEZ VOEPEL VOEPEL I
WOULD. WOULD NOT VOTING. THAT
HAS TWO AFFIRMATIVE VOTES THERE
ARE MANY MEMBERS- WHO WILL BE
ARRIVING LATER THIS MORNING
THANK YOU DR CHOI AND THANK YOU
TO THE WITNESSES WHO TOOK THE
TIME. T TESTIFY. LET'S DO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR NOW. FOUR ITEMS
ONTHE CONSENT CALENDAR AND-
THESE ARE ALL DO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS THERE'S A MOTION
AND SECOND ANY QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS THE ITEMS ARE AB TWENTY
SIX OH FOUR BY MISTER CALDERON.
AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY NINE BY
MISS CARILLO. AB TWENTY FOUR
FIFTY BY MISS VALLEY VALLADARES
. AND AB TWENTY SIX SIXTY ONE BY
MISS WALDRON. OF THOSE OF THE
FOR CONSENT CALENDAR ITEMS
THERE'S A MOTION AND SECOND
LET'S VOTE. DALY HI DALY AYE
MAYES AYE MAYES AYE BERMAN
BIGELOW. CALDERON CALDERON AYE
CERVANTES CERVANTES I GEN.
CRISTINA GARCIA COOPER GIPSON
GIPSON YE GRAYSON AYE GRAYSON
AYE RODRIGUEZ VOEPEL VOEPEL I
WOULD WOULD I. MR IF YOU THINK
IT'S APPROPRIATE TO MOVE- AB
TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY YOUR BILL.
THANK YOU YES NUMBER SIX YES- WE
NEED AND WE HAVE A MOTION AND
SECOND ON- AB TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTY. ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS- THE BILL WAS
PRESENTED BEFORE SOME OF YOU
ARRIVED BUT IT HAS BEEN
PRESENTED AND THERE WERE.
SPEAKERS FOR AND AGAINST ROLL
CALL VOTE PLEASE. FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIX AB TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTY MOTION IS DO PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS DALY AYE DALY AYE
MAYES AYE MAYES AYE BERMAN
BIGELOW CALDERON CALDERON AYE
CERVANTES. TORONTO'S I'D CHEN
CRISTINA GARCIA COOPER GIPSON
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE
RODRIGUEZ VOEPEL VOEPEL WOULD
WOULD I. HE THAT BILL HAS EIGHT
AFFIRMATIVE VOTES AND THEY'LL BE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO ADD ON LATER
THIS MORNING FOR THE RECORD-
CRISTINA GARCIA HAS BEEN. ADDED
FOR THIS HEARING ONLY. TO IN THE
PLACE OF MR COOLEY. WHO IS- IS
OUT WITH AN ILLNESS. SO WELL WE
WILL AWAIT MISSED GARCIA'S
ARRIVAL. LET'S GO ON I THINK- MR
REGGIE JONES SAWYER IS HERE TO
PRESENT. TWENTY FORTY THREE
REGARDING BAIL BONDS. WELCOME
YOU. THANK GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS ARE PRESENT AB
TWENTY FORTY THREE. WHICH WILL
ALIGN CALIFORNIA WITH EIGHTEEN
OTHER STATES BY REQUIRING BAIL
FUGITIVE RECOVERY AGENT LOCALLY
KNOWN AS BONNIE HUNTER'S TO
BECOME LICENSED BY THE STATE
CURRENT LAW AND BILL FUGITIVE
RECOVERY AGENTS IS LIMITED TO
UNENFORCEABLE EDUCATION NOTICE
AND CONDUCT STANDARDS AS NOTE
ENTITY IS CURRENTLY CHARGED WITH
IMPLEMENTATION AND NEARLY ALL
ENFORCEMENT OCCURS AFTER
VIOLATIONS OF THE LAW. DESPITE
BEING ASSOCIATED WITH BILL BOND
TRANSACTIONS THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT INSURANCE HAS BECOME
RECOVERY AGENTS THE FACT A
WATCHDOG DESPITE THE FACT THE
GAUGES ARE NOT LICENSE AND DO
NOT PAY ANY FEES TO SEE THE AYE.
NOT ONLY IS THERE A LACK OF IN
HOUSE SUPERVISION FROM INDUSTRY
WHEN HIRING OVERSEEING RECOVERY
AGENTS BUT THERE IS LITTLE ALSO
LITTLE RECOURSE FOR INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE HARMED ALSO WHEN A BAIL
RECOVERY AGENTS IS TERMINATED
FOR VIOLATING CALIFORNIA LAW
THERE IS ABSOLUTELY NO WAY TO
TRACK SUCH TERMINATION THUS
THESE INDIVIDUALS CAN BE HIGHER
BY EIGHT SEPARATE COMPANY
ALTOGETHER. AS SUCH AB TWENTY
FORTY THREE SIX TO SET THE
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK TO LICENSE
BAIL FUGITIVE RECOVERY AGENTS BY
REQUIRING AGENTS TESTING AND
PASSAGE TO OBTAIN A LICENSE
REVOCATION VERIFICATION BY
POSTING LICENSE RECOVERY AGENTS
ON THE INSURANCE COMMISSIONER'S
WEBSITE THE PASSAGE OF A PRINTER
PRINT BACKGROUND CHECKS.
ENSURING ONLY THOSE WHO RECEIVE
THE PROPER POWER OF ARREST
TRAINING CAN PERFORM AN ACTUAL
ARRESTS SINCE THE BILL HAS BEEN
INTRODUCED CDI AND MY STAFF HAVE
WORKED COLLABORATIVELY WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE THE MOST
COMPREHENSIVE IN PROPOSED
LICENSING PROCESS TO ADDRESS A
CONCERN REYES LAST THURSDAY I
WANTED TO FIRST NOTE THAT
CURRENTLY SURE T. INSURANCE
ALREADY APPOINT BILL AGENTS WHO
ACT AS QUOTE. UNQUOTE BONNIE
HUNTER'S ALSO REGARDING THE
LIABILITY COVERAGE REQUIREMENTS
NOT ONLY DOES THE ONE MILLION
DOLLAR INSURANCE COVERS ALIGNED
WITH WHAT IS REQUIRED OF
CALIFORNIA PRIVATE INVESTIGATORS
AND SECURITY GUARDS BUT ALSO SEE
I AND MY STAFF UPON MULTIPLE
INSURANCE COMPANIES THAT OFFER
COVERAGE. FOR BAIL RECOVERY
AGENTS. I A C. MADE IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS I AM
COMMITTED TO AMENDING THE BILL
TO INCLUDE LANGUAGE TAILORED
TOWARDS A DELAYED.
IMPLEMENTATION OF TO ENSURE THE
THERE ISN'T AVAILABLE AND
AFFORDABLE LIABILITY INSURANCE
PRODUCT FOR RECOVERY AGENTS
MEMBERS UNLIKE OTHER LICENSED
PROFESSIONALS IN OUR STATE THIS
OCCUPATION CAN HAS CAUSED
DRAMATIC IF NOT LIFE THREATENING
OUTCOMES. TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC AS SEEN MOST RECENTLY IN
PALM SPRINGS. THAT'S BY
REQUIRING BAIL RECOVERY AGENTS
TO BECOME LICENSED AB TWENTY
FORTY THREE WILL NOT ONLY
PROVIDE LONG TERM OVERSIGHT OF
HIS OCCUPATION BUT WILL ALSO
PROVIDE GREATER. CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS FOR OUR MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WITH ME IN A ROOM TO
SPEAK AS A SPONSOR AB TWENTY
FOUR THREE IS A MICHAEL MARTINEZ
SENIOR DEPUTY COMMISSIONER AND
LEGISLATE DIRECTOR ON BEHALF IS
OF INSURANCE COMMISSIONER.
RICARDO LARA. GO AHEAD SIR GOOD
MORNING A CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MICHAEL MARTINEZ
HERE BEHALF OF COMMISSIONER LARA
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE
WERE THE PROUD SPONSORS OF THIS
MEASURE AND WANT TO THANK THE
ASSEMBLY MEANT FOR HIS STRONG
LEADERSHIP AND- AUTHORING THIS
MEASURE. AND I'LL BE BRIEF AND
THAT- WE DO APPRECIATE THE
DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION DATE IN
ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THESE
PRODUCTS- THAT WOULD BE MANDATED
BY FOR COVERAGE BY THESE-
BILBREY FUGITIVE RECOVERY
PERSONS WOULD BE AVAILABLE IN
THE MARKET PLACE. AND THAT THIS-
BILL WOULD CREATE THE FIRST BILL
FUGITIVE RECOVERY AGENT LICENSE
IN CALIFORNIA. A LINE IN OUR
STATE WITH EIGHTEEN OTHER STATES
THAT HAVE EXISTING MANDATORY
LICENSURE IN PLACE FOR BOUNTY
HUNTERS TODAY. THIS BILL IS
NEEDED NOW TO RAISE THE STANDARD
FOR BAIL FUGITIVE RECOVERY
PERSONS TO APPREHEND BAIL
FUGITIVES AS WELL AS SIGNED AS
NECESSARY LIGHT ON THIS INDUSTRY
THERE'S T WILL ALSO
STRENGTHENED DEPARTMENTS ABILITY
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC. AND
HEALTH PREVENTS THE FUTURE
VIOLATIONS OF LAW THAT THREATEN
PUBLIC SAFETY WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST HER AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
MARTINEZ OTHER OTHER PERSONS
HERE WHO WISH TO. SUPPORT THE
BILL. ARE THE PERSONS HERE WHO
WISH TO. TESTIFY AGAINST THIS
BILL. I SEE ONE PERSON COMING.
FOR GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS
MY NAME IS KATHERINE BRANDENBURG
AND EVER PRESENT THE AMERICAN
BAIL COALITION I FIRST WANT TO
THANK THE ASSEMBLY MEN AND HIS
STAFF AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE FOR WORKING WITH US WE
AGREE WITH 95% OF THE BILL WE
AGREE THAT- IF LICENSES-
FUGITIVE AGENT SHOULD BE THEY
SHOULD BE LICENSED AND BUT WE DO
HAVE ONE ISSUE THAT'S REMAINING
TO WEAR RIGHT NOW THE BILL
STATES THAT. ON THE SURETIES
SOMEONE WHO HAS TO MAKE THE
APPOINTMENT AND NOTIFY THE
DEPARTMENT AND- NINETY PROBABLY
99% OF ALL. APPOINTMENTS TO
FUGITIVE- BELEK FUGITIVES THE.
MEMBERS BOUNTY HUNTERS I IS
ALWAYS TALKING LIKE I KNOWN AS
BOUNTY HUNTERS- BOUNTY HUNTERS-
ARE THE APPOINTMENTS MADE BY THE
BILL AGENT NOT BY THE SHERRY AND
SO WE ASSET THREE WORDS BE ADDED
TO THE BILL INTO PLACES
BASICALLY WOULD BE SURE EIGHTY
FOUR EIGHT OR BILL AGENT SO
WHOEVER IS ACTUALLY DOING THE
APPOINTMENT SHOULD MAKE THE
NOTIFICATION TO THE DEPARTMENT
AND BE THE ONE RESPONSIBLE FOR
NOTIFYING DEPARTMENT IF THERE'S
ANY CONCERNS- SO THAT IS THE
ONLY CONCERNED WE DO HAVE WITH
THE BILL WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE ASSEMBLY MEN.
AND THE DEPARTMENT INSURANCE ON
THIS ISSUE SO WITH THAT WE
RESPECTFULLY HAVE TO OPPOSE BILL
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ARE THERE OTHER PERSONS
WISHING TO. COMMENT OR SUGGEST
ANY CHANGES TO THE BILL OR
OPPOSE THE BILL. IF NOT WE'LL
COME BACK IN THE ORDER THE
COMMITTEE OTHER QUESTIONS FOR MR
JONES SAWYER- THANK YOU AS CHAIR
JUST WANTED TO SAY- GREAT BILL
OF LOVE TO BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR AS YOU REFERENCE THERE IS
AN INCIDENT IN MY DISTRICT WHERE
BOUNTY HUNTER- BUT SHOT AND
KILLED. ON A RESIDENTS- OF THE
BOUNTY HUNTER WAS A FELON- AND
SHOULD NOT HAVE BEEN A BOUNTY
HUNTER IT'S CRAZY TO ME THAT WE
DON'T HAVE A SYSTEM IN WHICH
BOUNTY HUNTERS ARE OUR LICENSE
IN THE STATE AND THERE'S SOME
RECOURSE- FOR THE FAMILIES OF
THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN INJURED BY A
BY THEM AND SO- AGAIN I WAS
GONNA REITERATE THAT I'M GONNA
MOVE THIS BILL WOULD LOVE TO BE
AS A CO AUTHOR IF YOU LOT MISTER
AUTHOR. OF ME AND- JUST MY VIEW
COMMENTS THANK MR VOEPEL HAS.
COMMENT HAVING BEEN INSURANCE
BUSINESS FOR THIRTY NINE YEARS
THROUGH THE YEARS I'VE OBSERVED-
QUITE A FEW. INTERESTING ITEMS
OUT IN THE FIELD WITH. BILLS
BONDSMEN AND BOUNTY HUNTERS-
GENERALLY PEOPLE DON'T JUMP BAIL
THEY SIGNED A CONTRACT.
GENERALLY THEY ARE DEPENDENT
UPON THE CONTRACT IT'S AN
INSURANCE CONTRACT. PAINT 10% OF
WHATEVER THE BAIL IS OR HIGHER
COULD BE HIGHER. AND THEY
GENERALLY DON'T BOUNCE BAIL THE
ONES THAT DO ARE THE BADDEST OF
THE BAD SO THIS IS A GREAT BILL
I'M GLAD TO SEE IT IT'S BEEN
NEEDED FOR LIKE THE LAST THIRTY
YEARS. AND. I WOULD LIKE TO.
SCHOOLS AND OUR CHILDREN AS WELL
TO YOU YOU CAN BE THE FIRST HERE
I LOVE THE BILL. DO THEY
ACTUALLY ARREST PEOPLE OR DO
THEY APPREHEND THEM THERE IS A
DIFFERENCE ENDEAVOR LEAVE IT UP
TO. YES IF YOU CURRENTLY HAVE MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE
APPREHEND THEM OKAY THANK YOU-
MIGHT WANNA MAKE A CORRECTION
MAKE THAT ONE YEAH THANK YOU
THANK YOU- I HAVE A QUESTION A-
THE PERSON WHO SUGGESTED A
SLIGHT MODIFICATION HOW DO YOU
FEEL ABOUT THAT MISTER JONES SO
WE'VE HAD AN EXCELLENT
RELATIONSHIP WITH SECURITY
COMPANIES- WE WANT TO MAKE SURE.
AS WHAT WAS MENTIONED EARLIER
THAT WHO'S EVER HIRED THE DARK
FELL INTO THAT THEY ARE THEY
DIDN'T COMMIT OF BUT A TRUSTEE
OR PROBLEM BEFORE THAT THE BAIL
AGENTS DON'T HIRE THEM AGAIN I
HAVE COMPLETE TRUST IN OBVIOUSLY
THE INSURANCE COMMISSIONER'S
OFFICE SO WE HAVE TO HAVE SOME
KIND OF ACCOUNTABILITY TO ENSURE
THAT DOES NOT A REOCCURRENCE
WHAT HAPPENED IN PALM SPRINGS
AND I THINK WE CAN WORK THROUGH
THAT AND CONVERSATION. PLUS- I
WILL PROBABLY TALK WITH ONE OF
THE MEMBERS HERE WHO HAD A OF A
IN EXPERIENCE IN INSURANCE I
THINK YES SIX OR SEVEN.
DIFFERENT LICENSES AND INSURANCE
AND WE MAY EVEN HAVE A RANDY AND
REGGIE BILL NEXT YEAR ON THIS
VERY TOPIC SO- I'M ALSO GOING TO
ENLIST HIS ADVICE ON WHAT IS THE
BEST WAY TO PROCEED WITH THIS
GOOD GOOD AND THANK YOU FOR
ACCEPTING THE IDEA ABOUT TO.
IMPLEMENTATION THE TIMELINE FOR
IMPLEMENTATION TO MAKE SENSE
THANK YOU OTHER OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. IF NOT I THINK WE
HAVE A MOTION AND SECOND DO WE
NOT MISTER MAYES MOTIONS AND-
SOMEONE SECONDED. MR VOEPEL
THERE YOU GO. THE REGGIE RAN A
RED ALLIANCE THAT AROSE STRONGER
BY THE MINUTE. SO MOTION AND
SECOND ANY OTHER QUESTIONS IF
NOT ROLL CALL VOTE. FILE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT AB TWENTY FORTY
THREE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS DALY AYE DALY AYE
MAYES MAYES AYE BERMAN BIGELOW
CALDERON. CALDERON AYE CERVANTES
CERVANTES AYE CHAN CHAN I
CRISTINA GARCIA COOPER GIPSON.
GRAYSON GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
RODRIGUEZ VOEPEL I VOEPEL I
WOULD WOULD I. GOOD THAT'S A HAS
NINE AFFIRMATIVE VOTES WHICH IS
THE MAJORITY. AND IT'LL PROBABLY
GROW AS WHEN OTHER MEMBERS
ARRIVE THANK YOU COMMITTEE THANK
YOU MISTER MARTINEZ THANK YOU.
UP MISTER CALDERON ARE YOU.
READY TO PRESENT. ONE OF YOUR
BILLS IS ALREADY BEEN APPROVED
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR AND-
THIS IS AB. TWENTY THREE SEVENTY
TWO. THIS MOTION IN SECONDS
ALREADY MARTIN GOOD MORNING THE
HI THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY TWO WOULD ALLOW FOR
PERSONAL INSURERS THAT DO NOT
SHARE PERSONAL POLICY HOLDER
INFORMATION TO NON AFFILIATED
THIRD PARTIES FOR MARKETING
PURPOSES TO SEND OUT THEIR
PRIVACY POLICY ONLY IF IT HAS
CHANGED. CURRENT LAW REQUIRES
INSURERS TO SEND OUT THEIR
PRIVACY POLICIES TO CONSUMERS AT
THE START OF A NEW POLICY AND
EVERY YEAR AFTER. IN ADDITION
INSURERS ARE REQUIRED TO
MAINTAIN THEIR PRIVACY POLICIES
ON THEIR WEBSITES AND PROVIDE IT
AT THE REQUEST OF A POLICY
HOLDER. THIS BILL SEEKING TO
REMOVE REDUNDANCY FOR ELIGIBLE
INSURERS AND REDUCE THE AMOUNT
OF UNNECESSARY PAPER WASTE
GENERATED. WITH ME IN SUPPORT IS
ALISON EIGHTY FROM THE PERSONAL
INSURANCE FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA. AND I HAVE ANOTHER
WITNESS BUT SHE'S TESTIFYING IN
ANOTHER COMMITTEE SO WE'LL SEE.
THANK YOU GO AHEAD GOOD MORNING
TURN MEMBERS I'M ALISON EIGHTY
WITH THE PERSONAL INSURANCE
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA PROUD
SPONSORS OF AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY TWO. CALIFORNIA INSURERS
ARE CURRENTLY OBLIGATED TO SEND
FULL PRIVACY DISCLOSURES
ANNUALLY UNDER BOTH THE I. P. P.
A. N. G. LBA. AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY TWO BRINGS CALIFORNIA
INTO CONFORMITY WITH THE
MAJORITY OF THE COUNTRY BY
ALLOWING INSURERS TO SEND THEIR
G. LBA NOTICED ONLY WHEN THERE
IS AN UPDATE OR CHANGE IN THEIR
PRIVACY POLICIES. OF COURSE
SUBJECT TO CERTAIN RESTRICTIONS-
INSURERS WILL STILL SEND THEIR
I. PPA ABBREVIATED NOTICES WHICH
WILL BE EXPANDED TO INCLUDE A
DESCRIPTION OF THEIR PRIVATE OF
PRIVACY RIGHTS AS WELL AS A WEB%
ADDRESS TO ACCESS THE FULL
POLICY SHOULD THE CONSUMER
DESIRE TO DO SO. THIS CHANGE
WILL REDUCE THE MILLIONS OF
REDUNDANT NOTICES THAT ARE
MAILED ANNUALLY WHILE ENSURING
CONSUMERS MAINTAIN ACCESS TO
THEIR POLICIES. WE APPRECIATE
THE WORK ON THE BELL AND URGEN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU ARE THERE OTHER
PERSONS HERE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. MARKET
SEGMENT WITH AMERICAN PROPERTY
CASUALLY INSURANCE ASSOCIATION
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL-
THIS IS A NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
INSURANCE COMMISSIONERS MODEL
BOLTON A PRIVACY NOTICES AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. MISTER MEMBERS
JOHN SHRIEKING ON BEHALF
ASSOCIATION A CALIFORNIA LIFE
AND HEALTH INSURANCE COMPANIES
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. OTHER
PERSONS WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. ARE THERE PERSONS
WISHING TO OPPOSE THE BILL.
ANYONE HERE IF NOT- COMMITTEE
IT'S BACK TO YOU ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FOR MISTER CALDERON
. WE HAVE A MOTION AND SECOND
ALREADY. SO YOU VÀ YOU HAVE ALL
THE DETAILS HANDLED AND LET'S GO
AHEAD AND VOTE ON THIS. UNLESS
YOU HAVE ANYTHING ELSE TO ADD.
THANK YOU MR CARE ACT LAST FOR
AN AYE VOTE OKAY. FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY TWO. MOTION IS DUE
PASSED APPROPRIATIONS DALY HI
DALY AYE MAYES. MAYES AYE BERMAN
BIGELOW CALDERON AYE CALDERON
AYE CERVANTES CERVANTES AYE
CHAN. CHAN I CRISTINA GARCIA
COOPER GIPSON. GIPSON I GRAYSON.
GRAYSON I. RODRIGUEZ VOEPEL
VOEPEL I WOULD I WOULD I. THANK
YOU. IT HAS NINE YES VOTESMISTER CALDERON FIGURE THAT WILL
LIKELY GROW ALL RIGHT ALL RIGHT
. WE'RE LOOKING FOR AUTHORS WE
HAVE A MISTER COOPER MR LEVINE.
MR ROD REGUS. AND MR EDUARDO
GARCIA WHO. HAVE YET TO PRESENT
THE COOPER'S NEXT DOOR AT THE
PURSE COMMITTEE- SO WE'RE
CALLING ON- EDUARDO GARCIA
FREDDIE RODRIGUEZ MARC LEVINE.
IF THEIR STAFFS ARE PAYING
ATTENTION OR THEY ARE PAYING
ATTENTION. MR LEVINE WELCOME.
THIS IS A THIS IS A PERFECT TIME
TO PRESENT. YOUR BILL. WE'VE
DONE YEP YOUR TIMING IS PERFECT
. GOOD MORNING. FURNITURE MY
WITNESSES SURE YEAH- GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB
TWENTY THREE TWENTY THREE
PREVENTS THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER IN KEY APPOINTED%
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE STAFF
FROM CONDUCTING A COVERED
COMMUNICATION UNLESS THEY
DISCLOSE AND PUBLISH THE
COMMUNICATION ON THE DEPARTMENT
WEBSITE THE PUBLIC INTEREST
PRINCIPLES OF FUNDAMENTAL
FAIRNESS AND DUE PROCESS OF LAW
REQUIRES THAT THE COMMISSIONER
AND DEPARTMENT STAFF CONDUCT
THEIR AFFAIRS IN AN OPEN
OBJECTIVE AND IMPARTIAL MANNER
FREE OF UNDUE INFLUENCE AND THE
ABUSE OF POWER. AND AUTHORITY.
AB TWENTY THREE TWENTY THREE
PROVIDES THAT THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER AND KEY
COMMISSIONER APPOINTEE SHALL NOT
MAKE A COVER COMMUNICATION LESS
THEY DISCLOSE AND MAKE PUBLIC
THAT COMMUNICATION BY REPORTING
AND PUBLISHING SUCH
COMMUNICATIONS QUARTERLY ON THE
DEPARTMENT'S INTERNET WEBSITE.
SPECIFICALLY THE DEPARTMENT
SHALL ADOPT A STANDARD
DISCLOSURE FORM FOR REPORTING
COVERED COMMUNICATIONS THAT
SHALL INCLUDE THE DATE TIME AND
LOCATION OF THE COMMUNICATION
THE IDENTITY OF THE PERSON OR
PERSONS INITIATING AND THE
PERSON OR PERSONS RECEIVING THE
COMMUNICATION. THE IDENTITY OF
THE PERSON ON WHOSE BEHALF THE
COMMUNICATION WAS MADE. THE
IDENTITY OF ALL PERSONS PRESENT
DURING THE COMMUNICATION. AND
THE TOPIC OF COMMUNICATION IN
ESSENCE. A CALENDAR ENTRY. TO BE
EFFECTIVE IN FOR A HEALTHY
ECONOMY CALIFORNIA'S REGULATION
OF THE BUSINESS OF INSURANCE
REQUIRES PUBLIC AWARENESS.
UNDERSTANDING SUPPORT
PARTICIPATION AND CONFIDENCE IN
THE COMMISSIONER. DEPARTMENT
STAFF AND THEIR PRACTICES AND
PROCEDURES ACCORDINGLY THIS BILL
IS NECESSARY TO PRESERVE THE
PUBLIC'S WELFARE THE INTEGRITY
OF THE REGULATORY PROCESS. AND
TO MAINTAIN THE PUBLIC'S TRUST
IN THE COMMISSIONER THANK YOU
DEPARTMENT APPOINTEES WITH ME
TODAY AS A WITNESS I HAVE COMMON
BOBBER OF CONSUMER WATCHDOG.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS THANKS FOR
HAVING ME HI MY NAME'S CARMEN
BULBAR AND THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CONSUMER WATCHDOG.
OF AND WE'RE HERE IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY THREE TWENTY THREE
CALIFORNIA'S INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER IS THE MOST
POWERFUL CONSUMER REGULATOR- IN
ANY STATE IN THE NATION. HE
MAKES DECISIONS THAT DALY AFFECT
THE POCKETBOOKS OF EVERY
CALIFORNIA INDIVIDUAL AND
BUSINESS OWNER- AS HE OVERSEES
THE THREE HUNDRED BILLION DOLLAR
PLUS INSURANCE INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA AND WITH THE POWER
AND AUTHORITY COMES THE
OBLIGATION FOR INTEGRITY AND
TRANSPARENCY. AND IT'S BEEN MADE
VERY CLEAR BY RECENT EVENTS THAT
CRITICAL DECISIONS AT CDI ARE
BEING MADE BEHIND CLOSED DOORS
AFTER THE COMMISSIONER AND THE
QUESTION IS TOP DEPUTIES MEET
WITH INTERESTED PARTIES IN THOSE
DECISIONS. IN TWENTY NINETEEN AN
INVESTIGATION UNCOVERED THAT THE
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER HAD TAKEN
CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTIONS FROM
INDIVIDUALS LINKED TO INSURANCE
COMPANIES WITH MATTERS BEFORE
THE AGENCY ONE OF THOSE
DECISIONS ARE ONE OF THOSE
COMPANIES WAS FACING ACTIONS BY
THE DEPARTMENT. FOR OVER
CHARGING BUSINESSES FOR THEIR
WORKERS COMPENSATION COVERAGE
THE COMMISSIONER THEN INTERVENED
IN THOSE PROCEEDINGS AND REVERSE
DECISIONS BY ADMINISTRATIVE LAW
JUDGES. COMMISSIONER LOTTA
LEADER ADMITTED THAT HE HAD MET
WITH THE PRESIDENT OF THE
COMPANY TO DISCUSS THOSE
DECISIONS AND ALSO THE STATUS OF
A MERGER OF THE COMPANY WAS
SEEKING. LATER THROUGH A PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT REQUEST AND THEN A
LAWSUIT THE CONSUMER WATCHDOG
WAS REQUIRED TO FILE BECAUSE THE
COMMISSIONER AND THE DEPARTMENT
WERE NOT FORTHCOMING WITH
RECORDS OF THESE MEETINGS AND
COMMUNICATIONS WE DISCOVERED
THAT OTHER OFFICIALS OF THE CDI.
HAD HAD UNDISCLOSED
CONVERSATIONS WITH
REPRESENTATIVES OF THIS
INSURANCE COMPANY INCLUDING
LOBBYISTS WHO HAD BEEN PROMISED
A TWO MILLION DOLLARS SUCCESS
FEE OF FOR WINNING THE MERGER
THE COMPANY WAS SEEKING. NONE OF
THESE PRIVATE MEETINGS WOULD
HAVE EVER COME TO LIGHT IF THE
CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTIONS HADN'T
FIRST DRAWN MEDIA ATTENTION BUT
THE PUBLIC HAS A RIGHT TO KNOW
THAT THESE COMMUNICATIONS ARE
HAPPENING WHO IS INFLUENCING THE
COMMISSIONER PRO ACTIVELY
INSTEAD OF HAVING TO WAIT FOR A
SCANDAL. THAT SPURS MEDIA OR
OTHER INVESTIGATION. AB TWENTY
THREE TWENTY THREE PROVIDES-
THAT TRANSPARENCY BY REQUIRING
THE COMMISSIONER IN ONLY THE
HIGHEST LEVEL APPOINTEES TO
RECORD AND REPORT THEIR
COMMUNICATIONS WITH INTERESTED
PARTIES AND THIS OLD ADDITIONAL
LEVEL OF TRANSPARENCY IS CRUCIAL
TO RESTORE THE PUBLIC'S
CONFIDENCE IN THE OPERATIONS AND
INDEPENDENCE OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF INSURANCE. SO AS AN
ORGANIZATION THAT FREQUENTLY
COMMUNICATES WITH THE CIA- AT
THE HIGHEST LEVELS WE WELCOME
THIS KIND OF SUNSHINE WE HOPE
THAT THE COMMISSIONER AND THE
INSURANCE INDUSTRY WOULD WELCOME
A WOULD WELCOME IT TOO WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY THREE
TWENTY THREE. THANK YOU MISS
BALLBAR ARE THERE OTHER PERSONS
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. ARE THERE PERSONS
HERE WHO WISH TO SPEAK AGAINST
THE BILL. I SEE ONE PERSON-
COMING TO THE FORE GO AHEAD SIR
THANK YOU THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SEREN TAYLOR
ON BEHALF OF THE PERSONAL
INSURANCE FEDERATION CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COMMENT ON AB TWENTY THREE
TWENTY THREE HOPEFULLY YOU SEEN
OUR LETTER AND KNOW THAT WE ARE
POSED TO THE BILL FOR SEVERAL
REASONS FIRST NOT EVERY BILL
AIMS TO BE ABOUT TRANSPARENCY
ACTUALLY IS. WE THINK AB TWENTY
THREE TWENTY THREE IMPOSES NEW
COMPLEXITY ON CD I OPERATIONS
THAT WILL WASTE TIME AND
RESOURCES BUT IT DOES NOT SERVE
THE PUBLIC INTEREST FOR
INCREASED TRANSPARENCY AS NOTED
IN THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS THERE
ARE NUMEROUS TRANSPARENCY LAWS
THAT CURRENTLY APPLY TO CDI
INCLUDING THE ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCEDURES ACT APA GOVERNING EX
PARTE COMMUNICATIONS AND THE
PUBLIC RESOURCES ACT P. R. A.
WHICH PROVIDES FOR ACCESS TO ALL
PUBLIC RECORDS AND INFORMATION.
YEAH I HAS ALSO ADOPTED AN
ADDITIONAL RULES THAT GO BEYOND
THE APA. SO IT IS ALREADY MORE
PROTECTIVE THAN OTHER STATE
ENTITIES OR EVEN REQUIRED TO BE.
HOWEVER THE MAJOR CONCERN WE
HAVE WITH THIS BILL IS NOT THAT
IT'S UNNECESSARY OR WASTEFUL.
IT'S THAT THE THREAT OF CIVIL
FINES AGAINST CDI STAFF FOR NON
COMPLIANCE WITH THE POTENTIAL
AWARD OF ATTORNEYS FEES AND
OTHER COSTS. WILL DISRUPT CDI
OPERATIONS AND CHILL THE
EXERCISE OF FIRST AMENDMENT
RIGHTS. BY DIS INCENTIVIZING THE
COMMISSIONER AND CDI APPOINTEES
FROM ENGAGING IN CONVERSATIONS
PERMITTED UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW.
WITH THE ENTITIES SUBJECT TO
REGULATION BY TI. INSURERS
ALREADY FIND IT CHALLENGING TO
WORK WITH CITY AYE BUREAUCRACY
AND ADDING LAWS THAT THREATEN
THE STAFF. AND INTERRUPT THE
FREE FLOW OF COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN STAKEHOLDERS. AND
ELECTED INSURANCE COMMISSIONER.
AT A TIME WHEN REALLY WE ONLY
GREATER COMMUNICATION AND
COLLABORATION. TO ADDRESS THE
CHALLENGES IN THE INSURANCE
MARKET. IS HARMFUL ALL
CALIFORNIANS. SO IN SUMMARY WE
THINK THIS BILL WILL INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY. BUT IT WILL IMPEDE
CITY I OPERATIONS CREATE
UNNECESSARY BARRIERS TO
COMMUNICATION FOR T THE CIVIC
AND- THAT'S ALL NEIGHBORHOOD.
BUSINESS LABOR TRADE OR SIMILAR
ORGANIZATION WHO NEEDS TO WORK
ON A MATTER BEFORE CDI. AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
TAYLOR. OTHER COMMENTS- IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL GOOD
MORNING MR DAILY. MEMBERS MATT
POWERS OF THE ASSOCIATION OF-
CALIFORNIA LIFE AND HEALTH
INSURANCE COMPANIES- I JUST LIKE
TO LET MYSELF FOR THE COMMENT
CALLING MR TAYLOR- WE CONTINUE
TO HAVE STRONG CONCERNS ABOUT
THE WORKABILITY OF THE REPORTING
THIS MEASURE REQUIRES. AT THE
CORE MISSION OF THE DEPARTMENT
AND ITS EMPLOYEES THE REGULATION
OF THE INSURANCE MARKETS. AND
THE PORT IN THE DEPARTMENT'S
RESOURCES FINITE. ADDING IT
DAILY AND WEEKLY ADMINISTRATIVE
BURDENS AND SERVICEABLE POORLY
DEFINED PROBLEM IS A DISTRACTION
FROM THE IMPORTANT WORK AND
RIGHT OF REGULATING CALIFORNIA'S
INSURANCE MARKET PLACE.
FURTHERMORE THE CIVIL PENALTIES
OF UP TO SEVENTY FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS PLUS LEGAL FEES- THIS
PROPOSAL SUBJECTS THE
DEPARTMENT'S EMPLOYEES TO. IT'S
COMPLETELY DISPROPORTIONATE TO
THE HARM AN INFRACTION WOULD
CAUSE. FOR COMPARISON NON FILING
OF F. PPC CAMPAIGN REPORTS ARE
SUBJECT TO TEN DOLLAR DAILY FEET
FINDS. SIMPLY PUT THE CIVIL
PENALTY PROVISION WILL INSTILL A
CULTURE OF FEAR. AND CUT OFF
COMMUNICATION WITH SENIOR
DEPARTMENT THE STAFF WHICH IS
INTEGRAL TO THE WELL FUNCTIONING
OF MARKETPLACE AND REGULATOR
THANK FOR MUCH. THANK YOU MISTER
POWERS OTHER. COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION. THIS IS YOUR MEMBERS
MAINLY ON BEHALF OF AMERICAN
PROPERTY CASUALTY INSURERS IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION ALIGNING
OURSELVES WITH PREVIOUS SPEAKERS
. GO AHEAD GOOD MORNING SHERRY
MCKEE REPRESENTING THE PACIFIC
ASSOCIATION OF DOMESTIC
INSURANCE COMPANIES IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THANK YOU
. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER COMMENTS
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS DO YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS FOR THE AUTHOR ON
THE BILL MR VOEPEL- A MINOR
QUESTION AND THEN A COMMENT IF I
MAY GO AHEAD. HOW LONG AGO WAS
THAT CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTIONS THAT
SPARKED ALL THIS OFF TWENTY
NINETEEN. AND THAT IS THE
CURRENT INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
CORRECT OKAY- MY COMMENT IS.
WHEN YOU CROSS INSURANCE
REGULATION WITH POLITICS THERE'S
GOING GOING TO BE SOME PROBLEMS
THERE ALWAYS HAS BEEN ALWAYS
WILL BE- I AM IN OPPOSITION AND
ALL THE POINTS MADE BY THE
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION- ABSOLUTELY
SPOT ON- LOOKING AT THIS FROM AN
INSURANCE PROFESSIONALS
VIEWPOINT. MANY TIMES THE
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER WILL
REACH OUT TO A BROKER A COMPANY
A BROKERAGE FIRM- EVEN ADMITTED
OR NON ADMITTED COMPANIES. WITH
ENQUIRE RES HEY WHAT DO YOU DO
IT BASICALLY NOW IF IT'S AN
INNOCENT INQUIRE RE ON A
COMPANY'S PERFORMANCE OR
PROCEDURES. MANY TIMES. THE
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER IS
SATISFIED NOW WHAT WILL HAPPEN
HERE IN THE CHILLING EFFECT
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT. IS I'M A
BROKER A INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
QUESTIONS SOME OF MY PRACTICES
WELL WITH THE DISCLOSURE WITHIN
SEVEN DAYS AND CIVIL FINES NOW
IT'S NOT JUST A ENQUIRING IT'S
NOT JUST. TRYING TO GET
INFORMATION ON THE REGULATORS
PART NOW IT'S A INQUISITION. IN
A CAN BE USED BY MY COMPETITORS
IT CAN BE USED IN MANY DIFFERENT
WAYS BECAUSE NOW YOU'RE ON
RECORD. SO THAT'S MY COMMENT
THERE SIR GOOD YEAH IF I IF I
MAY MISTER CHAIR- AND I RESPECT
MR VOCALS- CONCERNS IN IN
POSITION ON. I THINK THAT WHAT
GOT YOUR ATTENTION AND- AGAIN I
DON'T BELIEVE THAT THIS IS WHAT
COLOR YOUR ENTIRE VIEWPOINT OF
WHAT YOU'VE JUST SAID BUT BUT
WHAT YOU LEAD WITH WAS. WHEN DID
THE CONTRIBUTIONS OCCUR. AND THE
CONTRIBUTIONS AREN'T ACTUALLY
THE POINT OF THIS BILL THE
COUNTRY SINCE EARLY HAVE NO
IMPACT ON THIS BILL THE
CONTRIBUTIONS ARE ACTUALLY JUST
A MINOR PART. OF THE STORY. IT
WAS WHAT I DREW PEOPLE TO ASK
FOR MORE INFORMATION ABOUT
COMMUNICATIONS. WE WITHOUT THAT
WE WOULDN'T HAVE HAD THE PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT REQUEST TO
UNDERSTAND. YES IT COULD
CONTRIBUTIONS HAPPENED BUT THERE
WAS A SIGNIFICANT OVERRULING OF
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGES
DEALING WITH THAT THAT DONOR. SO
WHAT WAS IMPORTANT WASN'T THE
CONTRIBUTION WHAT WAS IMPORTANT
WHAT IS IMPORTANT. WHAT ARE THE
MEETINGS THAT OCCURRED THAT LED
TO OVERTURNING STAFF. THESE ARE
PEOPLE WHO ARE DEDICATED
PROFESSIONALS IN THEIR CAREERS
REGULATING A THREE HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLAR INSURANCE MARKET
THE FOURTH LARGEST INSURANCE
MARKET IN THE IN THE WORLD. WHAT
WERE THE COMMUNICATIONS THAT'S
WHAT THIS BILL GETS TO IT'S NOT
ABOUT THE POLITICS OF CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTIONS. WE JUST DON'T
KNOW WHAT THOSE COMMUNICATIONS
ARE SO IF YOU WANT TO UNDERSTAND
LIKE WHY. PUT AN INSURANCE
COMPANY THAT OVER CHARGED SMALL
BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA WHY
WOULD THEY BE LET OFF THE HOOK.
WHEN ALL OF THE STAFF REGULATORS
SAY THAT THEY SHOULD BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE YOU NEED TO KNOW
WHAT COMMUNICATIONS OCCURRED.
ALL RIGHT SIR ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR THE
ARCHER WHO HAD MISTER MAYES- I
THINK THAT THE AUTHORS UP.
PURPOSE IN THIS- IS IN
TRYING TO- TO WRITE SOMETHING HE
SEES AS A AS A WRONG- I JUST
HISTORICALLY NOT BEEN SUPPORTED
IN BACK ON MY TIME. AS A CITY
COUNCILMEMBER WHEN DEALING WITH
EX PARTE COMMUNICATIONS AS IT
APPLIED TO PLANNING
COMMISSIONERS. OF THE FIRST
MEMBER THE U. S. CONSTITUTION IS
VERY VERY CLEAR- AND ONE OF THE
MOST FUNDAMENTAL PARTS OF OUR
GOVERNMENT IS THE ABILITY TO
BUILD A PETITION- ELECTED
REPRESENTATIVES- WHEN I HAVE A
CONSTITUENT THE COMES. AND MEETS
WITH ME AND THAT CONVERSATION
THAT I HAVE WITH THAT
CONSTITUENT AS CONSTITUENT IS
PRIVATE BETWEEN ME AND THEM AND
THEN WE DON'T MAKE NOTES AND
TAKE NOTES WE DON'T PUBLICIZE.
OF THOSE THOSE CONVERSATIONS AND
I THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE- FOR
ELECTED OFFICIALS TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE CONVERSATIONS WITH THOSE
THAT ARE PETITIONING THEM AND I
THINK THE RULES THAT WE HAVE IN
PLACE IN REGARDS THE PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT AND OTHER THINGS- IS
MORE THAN ENOUGH- THAT THEN AND
I THINK THIS JUST GOES. A GOES
TOO FAR SO I WON'T BE SUPPORTING
THIS TODAY. THANK YOU MISTER
MAYES ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS- THIS BILL OF. IS ON
THE AGENDA TODAY AS A- THE
COURTESY TO THE AUTHOR WHO WE
ALL RESPECT- BUT THERE IS NO
RECOMMENDATION- MAKE GOES ALONG
WITH THE ANALYSIS- THE ANALYSIS
LAYS OUT ALL THE ISSUES IN THE
PROS AND THE CONS. SO WHERE DID
I HEAR A MOTION I DON'T THINK WE
HAVE ONE MOTION ONE MAKER OF THE
MOTION. IS THERE A SECOND. WELL
WE DON'T HAVE A FULL COMMITTEE
YET MR LEVINE THERE MAY BE
OTHERS WHO ARRIVE- MR COOLEY IS
OUTWITH AN ILLNESS AND THAT
THERE IS A REPLACEMENT FOR HIM
MISS GARCIA. SO WELL WE WILL- WE
WILL A- PROCEED WITHOUT VOTING
ON THIS BILL YET. WELL THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND THANK
YOU MEMBERS FOR CARRYING THIS
OUT THIS BILL IS NOT TO CHILL
COMMUNICATION AT ALL IT DOES NOT
STOP COMMUNICATION ONE BIT IT
DOESN'T SAY THAT YOU CAN'T
CONTACT THE REGULATOR AND STAFF-
SO IT DOES NOT DISCOURAGE THAT
AT ALL OF COURSE IF THERE ARE
ISSUES THAT HAVE LEGAL
PROCEEDINGS THAT IS COVERED
DIFFERENTLY- UNDER THE LAW SO IT
DOESN'T- REVEAL ANYTHING THAT
WOULDN'T OTHERWISE BE REVEALED
IN IN CERTAIN SITUATIONS MISTER
MAYES Y. I HEAR YOUR CONCERN
ABOUT THAT AS WELL. BECAUSE I
HADN'T IN THE PAST HAD CONCERNS
ABOUT EX PARTE COMMUNICATIONS
AND WHETHER OR NOT PEOPLE CAN
GET THE INFORMATION THEY NEED TO
MAKE GOOD DECISIONS- AND WE WANT
TO ENCOURAGE THAT TO IT- TO
OCCUR- SO AS THIS BILL KIND OF
SITS IN YOUR MIND AND YOU HAVE A
CHANCE TO DIGEST IT AND THINK
ABOUT THIS CONVERSATION- PLEASE
CONSIDER MAKING A SECOND. WHEN
NOT WHEN THE BILL COMES UP YET
AGAIN I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
DOCTOR WITH BY THE WAY FOR THAT
MOTION- I'M GRATEFUL FOR THAT
AND SO PLEASE WITH YOUR
CONSIDERATION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. THANK YOU MR LEVINE. AND
WE HAVE THREE OTHER AUTHORS
WAITING TO PRESENT IN MISTER.
EDUARDO GARCIA IS. IN THE ON
DECK CIRCLE AND COMING TO THE
PLATE. WELCOME MR GARCIA
HOPEFULLY WE GET A BASE HIT YEAH
YEAH. GIVE ME A NICE FAT PITCHER
HERE THERE YOU GO THANK YOU
THANK YOU ARE COLLEAGUES MISTER
CHAIR PREHEAT THE ANALYSIS DONE.
SECOND BAYAT YOUR COMMITTEE THIS
SUDDEN EFFORT TENDS TO ENSURE
THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS HAVE
ACCESS TO THE UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS WHEN- NEEDED YOU KNOW
THIS WILL PREVENT A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT TYPES OF SOCIAL
PROBLEMS THAT THAT WE ALREADY.
ARE TRYING TO TACKLE
HOMELESSNESS- YOU KNOW FEEDING%
OUR HUNGRY AND ULTIMATELY IT'S
ABOUT PUTTING OUR PRINCIPLES AND
OUR MORALS AS A STATE FORWARD TO
ENSURE THAT ALL PEOPLE HAVE
ACCESS TO THESE BENEFITS
RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR YOUR I.
BUT WE DO HAVE TWO PEOPLE
TESTIFYING LOSE GAY AIGLES
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR TOLD NICK
LEGAL CENTER AND OF THE
UNETHICAL PARK LEADER WITH THE
WAREHOUSE WORKER RESOURCE
CENTER. AND THEN WE ALSO HAVE
SOMEONE ON DECK TO PROVIDE ANY
TECHNICAL- ASSISTANCE WITH
ANSWERS QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY
HAVE THAT CAME UP WILL IT THANK
YOU MR GARCIA THE BILL ENJOYS A
SUPPORT RECOMMENDATION FROM THE
CHAIR. I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
EXCELLENT ALICE'S LET'S GO AHEAD
WITH YOUR WITNESSES YEAH YOU
WANNA GO FIRST GO YES THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS AN
IMPORTANT PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
AND TO THE ASSEMBLY MY GARCIA
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP MY NAME IS
LIZ GOT YEAH BECAUSE I AM
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF BUILDINGS
LEGAL CENTER BASED IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE AND THE COACHELLA VALLEY.
FOR ALMOST FORTY YEARS THOUGH
THAT HAS BEEN A HOPE FOR HEALING
ORGANIZING ADVOCACY AND
COMMUNITY TRANSFORMATION LED BY
THE PEOPLE WHO LIVE AT WORK IN.
THE ROLE INLAND COMMUNITIES. WE
ARE WE ARE ALSO WE FOR ALL.
BROUGHT WERE ALSO PART PROUD
PART OF THE SAFETY NET
PROCLAMATION. THE SAFETY NET
PROCLAMATION WAS FORMED AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC
BECAUSE WE KNEW THAT OUR
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES WOULD BE
THE HARDEST HIT BY THE COLD BIT.
NINETEEN WITH THE LEAST AMOUNT
OF SUPPORT. THE INTRODUCTION OF
AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY SEVEN AND
ITS VALUES. COME FROM TRUE FOR
THE TRUTH STRUGGLE AND THE
REALITIES OF OUR COMMUNITY. I
SHARE WITH YOU. I SHARE WITH YOU
I LOST THOSE PICTURE. A FORTY
NINE YEAR OLD FARM WORKER AND
HIS SIX YEAR OLD SON IN TWENTY
TWENTY ALFONSO WAS INFECTED WITH
COLBY ALTHOUGH HE WAS TOLD TO
STAY HOME AND SEEK HEALTHCARE HE
TOLD US IN OPEN UP A WHOLE NEW
FROM YOU KNOW FOR ME. IF I DON'T
WORK MY FAMILY WON'T EAT. I ALSO
WAS FOUND DEAD BY HIS SIX YEAR
OLD SON ON SUNDAY MORNING. ON A
SUNDAY MORNING. I SHARE A
PICTURE OF MY IDEA. A FORTY FOUR
YEAR OLD FARM WORKER MY YES
SUFFERS FROM ASTHMA DURING THE
TWENTY TWENTY A LOT ARE THE WILD
FIRES REGARDLESS OF THE BAD AIR
QUALITY CHECK COULD NOT AFFORD
TO STOP WORKING. SHE COME SHE
COLLAPSED IN THE FIELDS. SHE
TESTED POSITIVE FOR COBIT AND
SHE MISCARRIED A CHILD THAT SHE
HAD IN HER WILL. AB TWENTY EIGHT
FORTY SEVEN IS PERSONAL TO ALL
OF US. WE HAVE THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO USE OUR
PRIVILEGE TO PROTECT THOSE THAT
HAVE GIVEN THEIR ENTIRE WORKING
LIFE FOR OUR STATE'S ECONOMY.
AND HAVE NOT RECEIVED ANYTHING
IN RETURN. UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS
CONTRIBUTE TO WHAT YOU I TRUST
FUND THAT THEY WILL NEVER SEE.
THAT IT BACK IT'S NOT JUST WITH
AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY SEVEN
CALIFORNIA HAS THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PROTECT OUR GOLDEN STATE MOST
VALUABLE ASSET. OUR FARMWORKERS
AND ALL OUR IMMIGRANT WORK FORCE
THAT THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC
HAVE OFTENTIMES BEEN REPORT TO
ASK THE MOST THE SENSUAL BUT
THEN CONTINUE TO BE THE LEAST
APPRECIATED AND ALWAYS EXCLUDED
. LET YOUR CONSCIENCE BE YOUR
MORAL COMPASS TODAY AND VOTE IN
FAVOR OF AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY
SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU THE
PLEASE GO AHEAD WHEN I STATUS OF
THOSE ME NUMBER SEVEN AND NUMBER
FIVE. B. ONE THREE WHAT A SIGHT
CALIFORNIA SO I MEAN UMBRELLA
LIKE FROM THE LUCK WHEN YOU SEE
UNDER THAT THAT WOULD BE THAT
BUT I THOUGHT IT. IS THE YANKEE
BUT I BLOOD IS ALREADY FOR FANCY
OTHER WOUND AND BLOOD SO IT'S AN
IDEAL BUT I'VE BEEN SO NOTHING.
DOCUMENT THAT'S GONNA GO. WHAT
DOES BUT IT'S ON A THEM COME
WITH. BUT AT THE MOMENT BUT I
CALL. ONE OVER THE LEFT THEM
YEAH. YOUR GONNA HAVE A PROBLEM
IS THAT I'M- BUT I BEEN POST
MATHEMATICAL. SAID WHAT ABOUT
THE OTHER ONE PROGRAM OTHER THAN
SIMPLY OPENED UP ABOUT HOW TO
SEE ME ACTORS EXCLUSIVOS COMO YO
. THE M. FIVE. THE IMPOSTER DIED
UNDEFEATED LEFT SO YOU SEE IT ON
MY WILL MATCH THE FOR YOU SEE
LIVE. ESTADO DE FACTO NOT GOT
ANOTHER EVENT BILLS. DUNDURN
PRESS ABOUT THAT YET BUT UP FOR
THAT BY LETTING THEM BE LIVE YES
THEY LIKE FOR ME THAT. THE CAR
THAT THE YEAH. THE GRANT THIS
THAT THE AMPLE IN CONTRACT THAT
IRAQ HOPE WHAT I THINK WE'LL SEE
REALLY. WHAT COLOR MY GOD YEAH
THE LOCAL LISTINGS BUT ONCE IT
IDLES. S. AMAZE US AND BEAT US
THAT SADDAM WHAT COULD SEE WE
HAD ALMOST THE NEEDLE ONCE IS
THAT MOTHER THE SAME LEVEL ME
KAMANI THAT YOUR- NINE THIRTY
ALMOST IN A STUFFY PLUS THE ON.
NORTH ALMOST BILLION DOLLARS ONE
COASTAL. YOUR FOR YOU I'VE GOT
FOR ME. THAT MUCH OF NOT ADDRESS
. EITHER READY AT THE NET ACCESS
PHONE PROGRAM ON THE MAP WELL
YEAH LOS MOMENTOS MAS THE FEES
HE LEFT COMO PROGRAM OTHER THAN
IF YOU SEE OTHER THAT SIMPLY.
SECOND DON'T NOTICE ON BUT I
THOUGHT THE- BETTER FOR THE MOST
SYMPATHETIC BUT I'LL GO. ELEVEN
YOUNG SUPPORT UNTIL YOU SEE IT
THERE. IS SOME FIVE FIVE A
LENGTHY. BUT I POSTED WE DON'T
CALIFORNIA MUST WHAT THE IT IS
THAT THE WHAT IT I SEE SPENT
THE- THAT'S JUST PARTS THE M.
FOUR. IS BETTER CONTENT BECAUSE
OF WHAT BOTH. BUT I SAID I LOVE
IT THANK YOUR TRUCK WHAT IN
PLACE YET THEY- WE'RE NOT REALLY
THAT. GOOD ASK YES. MISTER WITH
YOUR PERMISSION I CAN TRANSLATE
TO HER STATEMENT IN LESS THAN
ONE MINUTE IF THAT IS- YOUR
DESIRE HE'S GO AHEAD THAT WILL
BE HELPFUL LIVE. MY UNDERSTOOD
TO SET THAT WITH MY AYE LIMITED
ON DANNY OF YOU DID BUT I WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT OTHERS
LISTENING- ALSO TAKE AWAY THE
IMPORTANT MESSAGE GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYONE. MY NAME IS AGAIN IT
WILL BITE AND I LIVE IN
RIVERSIDE CALIFORNIA I AM A
MEMBER OF THE SAFETY NET FOR ALL
COALITION. NAM HERE TO HIGHLIGHT
THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS FOR
EXCLUDED IMMIGRANT WORKERS LIKE
ME. MAYBE BY MY COMMUNITY LOST
THEIR JOBS WHEN THE PANDEMIC
BROKE OUT I WORKED AS A SERVER
FOR EVENTS. AND MY JOB SHUT DOWN
BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF ANOTHER
PRIVATE PROGRAM FOR EXCLUDED
WORKERS LIKE ME TIMES THAT WERE
ALREADY HARD. BECAME EVEN IF
MORE DIFFICULT- THIS CALL IS THE
CHAIN OF EVENTS WHERE I STRUGGLE
TO PAY RENT BILLS AND EVEN
GROCERIES. THIS MADE ME FEEL
STRESSED BECAUSE IF WE HAD
ANOTHER FROM A SYSTEM THAT
INCLUDED US. BY COMEDIAN I WOULD
NOT BE IN THE SITUATION WE'RE
NOT ASKING FOR SOMETHING UNFAIR.
SUPPORT CALIFORNIANS SO MANY
WAYS. AND SHOULD HAVE ACCESS TO
PROGRAMS THAT SUPPORT ME DURING
THIS MOST DIFFICULT TIME. I KNOW
THIS WON'T SOLVE EVERYTHING BUT
WE CAN START HERE AB TWENTY.
EIGHT FORTY SEVEN IS A STEP
FORWARD FOR BUILDING A STRONGER
MORE EQUITABLE RESILIENT
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY I HOPE TO COUNT ON
YOUR VOTES TO MAKE AB TWENTY
EIGHT FORTY SEVEN. A REALITY.
GOOD THANK YOU FOR THAT OF MR.
GARCIA AND FOR YOUR WITNESSES
AND THEIR TESTIMONY. AND I
UNDERSTAND YOU HAVE OTHER FOLKS
WHO WISH TO SPEAK. IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. I YOU DEARLY IF THERE
WILL BE SOME FOLKS SAT AT A NON
IS. ME TOO OKAY LET ME FIRST-
YEAH I THINK THIS IS THE TIME
ARE THERE FOR. PERSONS WOULD
LIKE TO ADD ON IS ME TO USE- AS
SUPPORTERS OF THIS BILL RIGHT
NOW. GO AHEAD. A GOOD AFTERNOON
I'M NOT ABOUT EITHER ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA EDGE COALITION
IN STRONG SUPPORT. LET ME- ASK
IF THE SPEAKERS COULD WAIT MR
GARCIA I'M REMINDED THAT THERE
WERE SOME PROPOSED AMENDMENTS IN
THE ANALYSIS OF THAT THERE WERE
AND WE- HAPPILY ACCEPT THEM
THANK YOU AND I ALSO. BELIEVE
THAT THERE WERE SOME DRAFTING
ERRORS THAT WILL BE CORRECTED AS
AS WE MOVE FORWARD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THAT THE PLEASE GO
AHEAD WITH YOUR SUPPORT. YES A
GOOD MORNING AND CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
VENICE AT THAT ON. A POLICY
DIRECTOR WITH THE MYSTICAL IN
THE CAN I COMMUNITY ORGANIZING
PROJECT AND ALSO A MEMBER OF THE
SAFETY NET FOR ALL COALITION. WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY EIGHT THANKS
VERY MUCH THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HEY GOOD MORNING GENEROUSLY
JENNY FLORES HARO ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR WITH MUSIC ON THE CAN A
COMMUNITY ORGANIZING PROJECT CO
FOUNDER OF THE ETAL FIVE AND
DOCU FUND AND BOARD CHAIRMAN OF
FAILING DOCUMENTS KENTUCKY FUND
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU- IN
THE MORNING- RICHARD AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MINING IS
CORNER SOLANO. AND SENIOR
COMMUNITY A NICER WITH MR GOING
TO CAN A COMMUNITY ORGANIZING
PROJECT. YOU MENDOZA CONNIE
ANGLING A MEMBER OF THE SAFETY
NET FOR ALL. A. N. ARE YOU
CALLING ITS RUN TO THE BORDER
THAT A. B. TWENTY EIGHT. EFFORT
SEVEN THANK YOU THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS ELIZABETH
MENDOZA- WITH THE SAFETY NET FOR
ALL COALITION OUT FROM US SAN
BERNARD DINO ON THE POLICY
DIRECTOR WITH ICY. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS RICARDO I'M I'M A
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT FROM THE
INLAND EMPIRE AND I'M ALSO-
TOTALLY CUTE MEMBER- HERE ON
BEHALF OF MY PARENTS WHO- ARE
ALSO UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS- AND
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORTER OF AB
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY SEVEN. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING JERRY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
BRIAN SANCHEZ AND I'M FROM THE
INLAND EMPIRE WITH. THE SAFETY
NET FOR ALL COALITION AND I'M
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY SEVEN. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS I'M OF ANY BILL I AM AT
FROM THE COACHELLA VALLEY A TODA
YOUTH MEMBER. A DOUGLAS ERA AND
ON BEHALF OF MY FAMILY AND MY
COMMUNITY I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY SEVEN.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS KARINA
CORONADO AND- AN ORGANIZER IN
THE COACHELLA VALLEY I'M ALSO
WITH THE SAFETY NET FOR ALL
COALITION. AND I'M CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
FORTY SEVEN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. ALLOW WINDOWS THE ADMIN
NUMBER IS THEN YEAH. HE IS LIKE
ONE OF THE SO WITH THAT BUT I
THOUGHT IT WAS A BEAUTIFUL SWAP
ALL YOUR HE'S WATER FOOD
MOMENTOUS BUT I COULD PERSONALLY
HAVE. TO SUPPORT THEY SEE IF HIT
US. GOOD GROCERY ASK THE VERY-
FROM THE COACHELLA VALLEY- ON
BEHALF OF MY FAMILY FORM. AND
COULDN'T BE. TO BECAUSE THEY NOT
WORK AND MAKE. I AM STRONG IN
FAVOR OF AB. TWO EIGHT FORTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU. ONE OF THE S.
MI NUMBER IS GOING TO SAVE UP OR
CHI YOU IS TO CALL UP ON HIS
UNDER THIS I WILL DO THAT BUT
THE LOS. YES THEY ARE KEEPING UP
WITH A LIST BUT UP IN THE LIST
WELL BEFORE YOUR- SO FOR YOUR IS
WHAT THE FEET MOMENT THAT BUT A
LOT OF AB GOOD SUPPORT AND THEY
SEE IT THEY GOT YES. GOOD MORE.
MY NAME IS MADDIE ALLY ALLY. AM
A YOUTH MEMBER OF TODAY. CENTER
FROM THE INLAND EMPIRE AND
RECENT GRADUATE FROM IDER
COLLEGE. I STAND BEFORE YOU IN
SUPPORT AND ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. OF AB TWENTY EIGHT
FORTY SEVEN WHICH WILL CREATE A
PILOT PROGRAM. TO PROVIDE.
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS TWO X.
EXCLUDED IMMIGRANT WORKERS THAT
CONTRIBUTE TO. OUR ECONOMY AND
OUR SOCIETY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
. ALUMINUM RENDERING NOT HAPPY
BEEN LOCAL EQUALITY UNDER THE
FACULTY THAT. EVEN A POSSIBLE
CULL. UP AGAIN A COUPLE YANKEL
AVE THOSE. MEDIA TALK WHEN THEY
FEEL THAT YOU HAVE BEEN OPEN UP
AGAIN MUCH OF THE- GOOD MORNING-
MY NAME IS CHRISTOPHER AND I AM
A MEMBER OF TOLD ACCUSED OF A-
YOUTH PROGRAM I HEAR FROM THE IN
AN EMPIRE. ON BEHALF OF MY
PARENTS AND MY COMMUNITY PLEASE
SUPPORT AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY
SEVEN THANK YOU. WELL ONE OF THE
ASSET THOUGH THOSE ME NO BUT AS
WE GET THE POINT THIS IS MICHAEL
EVAN WHO TO FIND I THOUGHT IS.
THAT THE BMW YOU'RE- TO HELP OF
STATUS A LOT OF IT BEING TO WHEN
BY FIFTY GET A FEW MY YOUNG.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS RAY. OF
THE- TELETECH. USE AND THE
INLAND AND- FOR. AND I'LL BE. OF
MY GRAMMAR WHO IS NOT ABLE TO BE
HEARD BECAUSE YOU HAD TO WORK IN
THE FARM- TO SUPPORT OUR FAMILY.
AND MY COMMUNITY WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY
SEVEN THANK YOU. HELLO EVERYONE
MY NAME IS SONNY A LOT I AM WITH
THE SAFETY NET FOR ALL COALITION
A POLICY COORDINATOR WITH THE
CALIFORNIA GROUP IMMIGRANT
POLICY CENTER URGING ALL OF THE
MEMBERS IN THE INSURANCE
COMMITTEE TODAY TO VOTE AS FOR
AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY SEVEN
THANK YOU. HELLO MY NAME IS
JULIAN I AM MEMBER OF TODAY FROM
THE INLAND EMPIRE. AND THE
SAFETY FOR ALL PROGRAM. ON
BEHALF OF MY DAD IN THE WORKING
COMMUNITY AND ADVOCATING FOR IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
FORTY SEVEN THANK YOU. HELLO
CHAIR AND MEMBERS YES AND YEAH
HE MENACE POLICY ASSOCIATE WITH
GRACE AND HERE IN SUPPORT OF
SAFETY NET FOR ALL AND ALSO THE
END CHILD POVERTY COALITION WITH
OVER A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
MEMBERS VOTING THIS IS A TOP
PRIORITY THIS YEAR. THEY KEEP.
MORNING COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS NATHAN CHEUNG AND I'M
WITH THE STATE NOT FOR ALL
COALITION. AS AN ORGANIZER AND
ALSO AS AN INDIVIDUAL AS AN
IMMIGRANT. WHO HAS HAD TO AND
EXPERIENCE FIRST HAND THE UNJUST
AND CRUEL EXCLUSION. FROM
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS WHEN I WAS
WORKING AT A RESTAURANT. AND
ALSO THE GRADUATE TEACHING.
ASSISTANT AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA LOS ANGELES. AND I
URGE YOU ALL TO VOTE. HI FOR AB
TWENTY FORTY SEVEN THANK YOU. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON A CHAIRED MEMBERS
ALEXIS CASTRO GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER- WITH
THE CHAIRS- PERMISSION- BEEN
AUTHORIZED TO READ- WE HAVE A
COUPLE ORGANIZATIONS- THAT'S A
DIRECT. LEGAL SERVICES IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY NATIONAL BUT
OF THE FEDERAL YOU'LL INDICANDO
WALKING OUT IN SUPPORT. CHILD
CARE LAWCENTER IN SUPPORT CLEAN
CAR WASH WORKER CENTER IN
SUPPORT. HER COURAGE CALIFORNIA
ELLA BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS AND POVERTY IN CALIFORNIA
EPIC EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES
INDIVISIBLE CALIFORNIA STATE
STRONG. LONG BEACH IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS COALITION NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER. NATIONAL
COUNCIL OF JEWISH WOMAN
CALIFORNIA NATIONAL COUNCIL
JEWISH WOMAN SACRAMENTO NATIONAL
EMPLOYMENT LAW PROJECT. POMONA
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY CENTER
SHIELDS FOR FAMILIES SO I RAN
THE CENTER FOR WORKERS RIGHTS
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY. COMMUNITY LABOR CENTER
UC MERCED. PROSELYTISM NEEDLES
WORKERS UNITED LEGAL AID AT WORK
AND WAREHOUSE WORKERS. RESOURCE
CENTER IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN MURS MITCH SNIDER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
ALSO IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ARE THERE ANY OTHER
PERSON'S WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. ARE THERE
ANY PERSONS HERE WHO WISH TO
SPEAK AGAINST THE BILL. THERE
APPEAR TO BE NON- IMPRESSIVE.
THE LIST OF SUPPORTERS MR
GARCIA- COMMITTEE MEMBERS DO YOU
HAVE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS GO
AHEAD MR WOULD- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND- SO I'M VERY
SYMPATHETIC TO WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH HERE- IN MY
DISTRICT THERE ARE MANY PEOPLE-
AGRICULTURAL WORKERS FOR
EXAMPLE- WHO WORK AS AN EMPLOYEE
AND QUALIFY FOR YOU WHY. EVERY
DAY BUT FEDERAL LAWS OBVIOUSLY
PREVENT THAT SO I THINK IN THIS
SCENARIO I THINK THIS IS A GREAT
EXAMPLE CALIFORNIA VALUES MY
APOLOGY FOR BRING TO GO FORWARD
I AM HOWEVER CONCERNED A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THE CHALLENGE OF
COLLECTING CONSISTENT DATA- TO
PREVENT FRAUD. WHILE PROTECTING
THE IDENTITY IN THE PRIVACY OF
APPLICANTS SO I KNOW IT'S THE
FIRST HEARING FOR THE BILL- I'M
GONNA SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY BUT
I HOPE THAT WE CAN GET MORE
CLARITY AROUND THAT- AND- AS AS
THE BILL MOVES FORWARD. ALL
RIGHT. MISTER GRAYSON HAD A
QUESTION THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND A COMMENT FIRST- MY HEART
DOES GO OUT TO THE MANY. HARD
WORKING WOMEN AND MEN. THAT
LABOR IN THE FIELDS OF
CALIFORNIA. AND THE SERVICE
WORKERS PARTICULARLY IN THE FOOD
SERVICE THAT FEED FAMILIES- HERE
IN CALIFORNIA AND YET THEY
STRUGGLE TO FEED THEIR OWN. AND
ALONG WITH THE MANY VETS AT
LABOR AND SO MANY OTHER
PROFESSIONS AND MAKE UP THE
LABOR COMMUNITY OF CALIFORNIA
THAT REALLY SUPPORT AND
UNDERGIRDED KANEMI. OF OUR
STATE. I I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY
THAT AS THOUGH I BELIEVE IT'S
ALREADY BEEN SPELLED OUT BUT TO
CLARIFY. THESE ARE HARD WORKING
WOMEN AD MEN THAT CONTRIBUTE TO
A SYSTEM FOR WHICH THEY HAVE NO
ACCESS. AND OF THIS IS NOT ABOUT
GIVING AWAY SOME TYPE OF
UNDESERVED BENEFIT BUT IT REALLY
IS ABOUT JUSTICE AND IT REALLY
IS ABOUT ADEQUATE ACCESS. OR OR
ACCESS MY RIGHT BECAUSE THEY'RE
ALREADY A PART OF THE GIVING
THEY JUST DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
THE RECEIVING END OF IT SO I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR VERY
MUCH FOR WHAT YOU ARE
ACCOMPLISHING ATTENDING TO DO
HERE. I DO HAVE THE SAME-
CONCERNED ABOUT SOME CLARITY- AS
WE MOVE FORWARD- WANTING TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE REALLY JUST GET
THIS DOWN AND GET IT- GET IT
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT- AS WE MOVE THE
BILL FORWARD SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU MISTER GRAYSON
MISTER GIBSON ADDED COMMENT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING-
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY SEVEN I AM.
PROUD CO AUTHOR OF THIS BILL-
CERTAINLY THIS PANDEMIC HAS HIT
SO MANY FAMILIES ALL UP AND DOWN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND FOR
THE REASONS THAT MY COLLEAGUE-
STATED- THIS ISN'T- UNDOCUMENTED
INDIVIDUALS PAY INTO THE CAN'T
RECEIVE AND THIS WE CAN HAVE TO
CALIFORNIANS. RIGHT WE JUST
CAN'T HAVE TO CALIFORNIANS AND
FEEL GOOD. AND WE HAVE TO LOOK
AT THE DISPARITY WE HAVE TO LOOK
AT THE ON EQUABLE HONEST- THAT
EXIST IN OUR LAWS AND CHANGE
THOSE AND I THINKING AND
APPLAUD- YOU KNOW- MISTER GARCIA
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL BEFORE US
I THINK IT MAKES ABSOLUTE.
BOTTLE AND COURAGEOUS SENSE-
THAT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
OUR BROTHERS AND SISTERS IN THIS
STATE WHO PROVIDES WHOSE TAKE
CARE FAMILIES. HAVE THE SAME
KIND OF BENEFITS LIKE EVERYBODY
ELSE IT'S ABOUT BALANCE ABOUT
BEARS ABOUT JUSTICE. AND
CERTAINLY THIS BILL PROVIDES
THAT KIND OF BALANCE THAT I'M
HAPPY- THAT THIS BILL IS BEFORE
US TODAY AND SERVE AS A CO
AUTHOR WILL BE A DOOZY ETHICALLY
BE SUPPORT IN THIS BILL. A
BECAUSE IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO
DO NOT HAVE TO CALIFORNIA'S ONE
CALIFORNIA THAT INCLUDES
EVERYBODY KNOCKS GLUED. THANK
YOU MISTER GIBSON MISTER GIBSON
MADE THE MOTION- AND- MR ROD
REGUS SECONDED THE MOTION- MR
GARCIA WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
UP. POINT WELL NOTED DUCKED BACK
TO WHAT- IT IT'S A SECRET THAT
THE UNEMPLOYMENT DEPARTMENT OR
AGENCY- IS OF NEED A SIGNIFICANT
OVERHAUL AS IT RELATES TO
EFFICIENCIES. AND ITS DELIVERY
OF THE SERVICES AS WELL AS THE
RAIL GUARDS TO MAKE SURE THAT-
THERE AREN'T ANY FRAUDULENT
CASES GOING THROUGH THERE I WILL
NOTE THAT- THE FRAUDULENT CASES
THAT WE DID HEAR ABOUT. A DURING
THIS PANDEMIC ALL HAVE TO DO
WITH THE NEW PROGRAM OR FOR THE
MOST PART WITH A NEW PROGRAM
THAT WAS ESTABLISHED- BUT NEVER
THE LESS I THINK THAT THAT WE
CAN WORK IN PARALLEL. TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE IMPROVE THE SYSTEMS
AND THAT WE'RE ALSO DELIVERING
ON OUR COMMITMENT TO
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
CONTRIBUTING SIGNIFICANTLY TO
OUR ECONOMY AND IS AS WAS SAID
RIGHT THAT THESE ARE INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE CONTRIBUTING. TO THE
SYSTEM TO THE SOCIAL SECURITY
SYSTEM AND DIES CURRENT LAWS THE
STANDS WILL NEVER SEE A SINGLE
PENNY. RETURNED TO THEM- DURING
THEIR LIFETIME BUT WE HAVE A
UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY HERE TO
CHANGE THAT AND CALIFORNIA AND
THE FOR THOSE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. ALL
RIGHT TO ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS SO WELL DONE MR
GARCIA. AND OWN WE WILL VOTE NOW
. FILE ITEMSEVEN AB TWENTY
EIGHT FORTY SEVEN MOTION IS DUE
PASSED AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS DALY HI DALY AYE
MAYES. MAYES AYE BERMAN BIGELOW.
CALDERON CERVANTES CERVANTES AYE
CHAN. CHEN NOW CRISTINA GARCIA.
COOPER GIPSON I GIPSON AYE
GRAYSON GRAYSON I RODRIGUEZ
VOEPEL WOULD WOULD I. THE BILL
HAS SIX AFFIRMATIVE VOTES AND
NOW THEY'LL BE AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR THE REMAINING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO VOTE WHEN THEY ARRIVE
THANK YOU- MR RODRIGUEZ WAS HERE
AND THERE IS. PERFECT TIMING
MISTER ROD REGUS GO AHEAD WITH
AB TWENTY SIX FOURTEEN. THANK
YOU MISTER MEMBERS AB TWENTY SIX
FOURTEEN IS A WORKER PROTECTION
STUDY BILL WOULD REQUIRE THE
COMMISSION ON HEALTH AND SAFETY
WORKERS COMPENSATION TO CONDUCT
A STUDY ON WORKERS COMPENSATION
INSURANCE. THERE IS EVIDENCE
THAT THERE ARE SOME STAFFING
AGENCIES IN CALIFORNIA THAT HAVE
CREATED A NICHE INDUSTRY BY
SELLING THEIR ABILITY TO LOWER
AN EMPLOYER'S WORKMAN'S COMP
COST THEY DO THIS BY SO MANY
EMPLOYEES FROM CLIENT PROVIDERS
WHO ABOUT WORKERS COMP RATING
FOR THEM PLOY THEN HAS A LOWER
WORK COMP PAYMENT THAT DOES NOT
REFLECT WHAT THEM PLOY. ACTUALLY
DOES FOR A LIVING INSTEAD THE
WORKING INSTEAD OF WORKING TO
GET A BETTER WORKING COOERATING
BY REDUCING WORKPLACE INJURIES
THESE BAD ACTOR EMPLOYERS ARE
USING THIS LOOPHOLE TO AVOID
HIGHER WORKMAN'S COMP COST. WITH
ME TO PROVIDE IN PERSON
TESTIMONY IS NOT READY WHO IS
REPRESENTS THREE FORCE AND
SPONSOR OF THE BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU GO AHEAD MISTER
MORETTI MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MATT
READY ON BEHALF OF THE FORCE-
THIS IS A BILL THAT WE WORKED
WITH STARTING IN JANUARY TRYING
TO BRING A LOT OF STAKEHOLDERS
IN WORKERS COMP TOGETHER. I JUST
WANT TO SAY- WE THINK WE GOT
THERE THIS COMPROMISED WITH THE
STUDY BILL IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS I'M HERE TO ANSWER
THEM THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER
PERSONS HERE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR OF THIS. STUDY BILL.
ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK AGAINST
IT. COMMITTEE MEMBERS DO YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FOR MR ROD
REGUS. MISTER GRAYSON YOU WE
HAVE QUESTION I MOVED. OKAY. WE
NEED A SECOND. MOTION AND SECOND
ON THE BILL MISTER ROD REGUS ANY
CLOSING COMMENTS HOUSE REGRESSED
RIVAL THANK GOOD GOOD- LET'S
VOTE ON THIS. FILE ITEM NUMBER
TEN AB TWENTY SIX FOURTEEN
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS DALY OUR DAILY
AYE MAYES. MAYES I BERMAN
BIGELOW CALDERON CALDERON AYE
CERVANTES. CHEN CRISTINA GARCIA
COOPER GIPSON GIPSON AYE GRAYSON
GRAYSON AYE RODRIGUEZ AYE
RODRIGUEZ AYE VOEPEL VOEPEL I
WOULD WOULD I. THAT IS EIGHT
AFFIRMATIVE VOTES INTHE VISIT
WILL BE AN OPPORTUNITY TO ADD ON
THANK YOU YOU VOTED THEY DID YOU
VOTE OKAY GOOD GOOD. BUT JUST
DOUBLE CHECK IN GOOD JOB MR
RODRIGUEZ AND- THE LAST BILL IS
MISTER COOPER'S BILL. AND DO WE
KNOW HOW THEY'RE DOING NEXT DOOR
IN THE PERS COMMITTEE. ALMOST
WRAPPED UP. MR BERMAN ALL RIGHT. A LITTLE LET'S GO AHEAD AND
LIFT THE- LET'S GO AHEAD AND DO
SOME ADD ON'S RIGHT NOW WHILE
WE'RE WAITING FOR MR COOPER.
THAT WORK FOR YOU MISTER BERMAN
. OKAY OKAY WE AIM TO PLEASE.
I'M I'M PRO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. I TRY. IT COULD. IT
WILL APPLE SERVICE. WE'RE GONNA
DO THE CAN SO CALENDAR BERMAN
BERMAN I. CHEN CHEN I CRISTINA
GARCIA COOPER RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I. FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE TWENTY THREE SEVENTY TWO
BERMAN BERMAN I. CRISTINA GARCIA
COOPER RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB FIFTEEN
NINETY SIX. BERMAN HI BERMAN AYE
BIGELOW. THE CHEN CHEN I.
RODRIGUEZ. RODRIGUEZ NOT VOTING. THEN I'LL COME BACK UP OKAY
OKAY THE GOAL YEAH THAT WORKS
WITH THE. ALL RIGHT DID YOU AND
DID YOU. COMPLETE THE ONES THAT
I HAD YEAH OKAY YOU WANT DO. IS
GO AHEAD. WELCOME MR COOPER
WELCOME BACK THE GO AHEAD HERE
GO AHEAD- CHAIR MEMBERS AB
TWENTY EIGHT NINETY FOUR
REQUIRES A LICENSE CONTRACTOR TO
FORM THE CONTRACTORS STATE
LICENSE BOARD. OTHER WORKERS
COMPENSATION CLASSIFICATION
CODES ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL
REQUIRES C. S. L. B. TO POSTED
INFORMATION ON ITS INTERNET
WEBSITE CURRENTLY C. S. L. B.
LICENSE STATUS LOOK UP TOOLS
SHOWS WHETHER OR NOT A COMPANY
IS CARRYING A WORKERS
COMPENSATION INSURANCE POLICY.
BUT AS LONG IN THE CAPE THE FOUR
DIGIT WCC CODE ASSOCIATED WITH
OBTAINING THE POLICY. SINCE
RATES FOR WORKERS COMPENSATION
INSURANCE VARY BASED ON THE FOUR
DIGIT WCC CODE USED SOME
CONTRACTORS MAY INTENTIONALLY
MISCLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES TO
OBTAIN LOWER RATES. AB TWENTY
NINETY FOUR PROJECT WORKERS BY
REQUIRING A LICENSE CONTRACTORS
PROVIDE INFORMATION TO SEE SLB
TO ASSURE EMPLOYEES ARE PROPERLY
INSURED AND OUT ABLE PREVENT
UNSCRUPULOUS CONTRACTORS WERE
BURSTING LESS EXPENSIVE ASSURE.
INSURANCE COVERAGE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE
KEEP THAT WITH THE DISTRICT
COUNCIL FIRE WORKERS PROUD
SPONSORS OF THIS LEGISLATION I
WOULD JUST ADD IN ASKING FOR
YOUR VOTE THAT THE- ONE OF THE
OPPOSITION VOTES IN THEIR FIRST
COMMITTEE ACTUALLY. REVIEW THE
BILL AND HAS SINCE BEEN ASKED TO
AT BE ADDED AS A CO SPONSOR SO
IS BIPARTISAN BILL WOULD ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MR
DONE- OTHER PERSONS HERE WISHING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
. MORE MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MIKE
MONEY GOING TO BE HALF OF THE
NEARLY FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND%
WOMEN AND MEN IN THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY THROUGH
THE- MEMBERSHIP IN THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
BIRDS MITCH SNIDER WITH
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION ALSO
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
PERSONS WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. ARE THERE
PERSONS HERE WISHING TO SPEAK
AGAINST THE BILL. THERE ARE
NONE- COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE
QUESTIONS FOR MR COOPER. ALL
RIGHT BE GOING EASY ON HIM TODAY
. OKAY DO WE HAVE A MOTION AND
SECOND I KNOW AFFECT I'M SURE WE
DID. GOOD GOOD GOOD THERE'S A
MOTION AND SECOND LET'S VOTE ON
THIS BILL. GOOD JOB MR GROUP
EITHER. FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB
TWENTY EIGHT NINETY FOUR MOTIONS
DO PASS APPROPRIATIONS DALY HI
DALY AYE MAYES MAYES AYE BERMAN
BIGELOWCALDERON. CALDERON AYE
CERVANTES CERVANTES AYE CHAN
CHAN I CRISTINA GARCIA COOPER HI
COOPER AYE GIPSON. IT GIPSON AYE. GRAYSON REASON I RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ AYE VOEPEL. WELL I
WOULD WOULD I YOU KNOW YOU JUST
VOTED THREE TIMES IN MY- OKAY.
THAT BILL PASSES HOW MANY VOTES
ELEVEN YES VOTES. THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ADD ON FOR. THIS
GARCIA THANK YOU. MISTER SEA AND
THEN ONE OR TWO OTHER MEMBERS I
THINK YEAH. YEAH SO I CAN. YOU
KNOW I. CONSENT CALENDAR COOPER
COOPER I.
COOPER. BUT FILE NUMBER ONE
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY TWO COOPER
COOPER I. FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR
. COOPER. THE VOTING OR NOT
VOTING. FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE.
BERMAN. BERMAN I. FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIX TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY
BERMAN BERMAN I. CHEN CRISTINA
GARCIA COOPER COOPER I RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I. FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT FORTY SEVEN
BERMAN BERMAN I CALDERON
CALDERON AYE COOPER COOPER II
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE VOEPEL.
I DON'T VOEPEL I. CORRECT FILE
NUMBER. EIGHT TWENTY FORTY THREE
BERMAN HI BERMAN I. COOPER
COOPER I RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I.
RIGHT NOW. FOR LEGISLATIVE YEAH
I READ MY WORLD TRADE CENTER
TRAIN OFF ONE ITEM SEPARATE.
REPORTER CHANGE MY BUT IT
REQUIRES WHEN A ALREADY. SEVEN
YES YEAH SIR GO AHEAD MR VOEPEL
TO FILE NUMBER SEVEN. AB TWENTY
EIGHT FORTY SEVEN VOEPEL NO
VOEPEL NOW. ASSEMBLY I KNOW I
KNOW. WE'RE STILL ARE OFFERING
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR FOLKS TO ADD
ON MISTER COOPER I IT'S WORKING
FOR MY VOTE ON NINE. ON NINE
THERE WAS NO SECOND SO THERE'S A
LOT ARE PERFECT. WHAT WAS AN
APPLE USER STUDENTS OKAY. OKAY
FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN AB TWENTY
SIX FOURTEEN BERMAN BERMAN I.
CERVANTES CHEN- TWENTY SIX
FOURTEEN. CERVANTES I CHEN
COOPER COOPER I. SO OKAY YEAH
YEAH HELLO. WELL DONE DOUBLE
CHECK YOUR GOVERNMENT SECOND.
YOU WERE VERY EFFICIENT TODAY
THIS. WITH THAT TIME OF MORE IN
THE YEAR WHAT OTHER COMMITTEE
ONE PERSON PERCENT. LOCAL MY
DOCTOR CALLED RUNNING. RESEARCH
WORKING SO I TO MAKE A LOT OF
TROUBLE THAT YOU ARE GOOD
BEAUTIFUL COME OUT OKAY ON AND
GO- YOU'RE GONNA DO IT OKAY.
YEAH. GOOD LUCK AND- C.
WE ARE WAITING FOR MS GARCIA TO
ADD ON AN- I'M TOLD SHE'S ON HER
WAY. WE WON'T ADJOURN THE
MEETING UNTIL WE- GIVE MS GARCIA
EVERY OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE.
CONSENT CALENDAR CRISTINA GARCIA
ASCENA GARCIA I FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE TWENTY THREE SEVENTY TWO
CRISTINA GARCIA. CALDERON HOW I.
CRISTINA GARCIA HI FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR AB. FIFTEEN NINETY
SIX CRISTINA GARCIA. SORRY AB
FIFTY NINETY SIX CHOI. NOT
VOTING. FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB
TWENTY EIGHT NINETY FOUR COOPER
CRISTINA GARCIA. CRISTINA GARCIA
I. FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX AB
TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY DALY
CRISTINA GARCIA. I. FILE ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN AB TWENTY EIGHT
FORTY SEVEN EDUARDO GARCIA
CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA
I. FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB
TWENTY FORTY THREE JONES SAWYER
. CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA
GARCIA I. FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN
EIGHTY TWENTY SIX FOURTEEN
RODRIGUEZ CRISTINA GARCIA
CRISTINA GARCIA HI. THANK YOU
ESPECIALLY IF. THE BILL THERE.
SO EVERYONE HAS VOTED. ALL I
SHOULD SY ALL THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS HAVE VOTED ON THESE
BILLS. AND I WILL READ THE FINAL
. THE VOTE COUNT.
THIS MAKE TODAY OKAY. JUST LOOK
AT A COUPLE OF LITTLE TIDBITS
THAT I DIDN'T HAVE A CHANCE TO.
YOU CAN TAKE ALL. OKAY SORRY
OKAY DO I OKAY CAN I READ YOUR
WRITING OR SHOULD I JUST ON- I
CAN READ IT SURE CONSENT
CALENDARS THIRTEEN ZERO ZERO.
THE CAN CALENDAR OF FOR TODAY
WAS THIRTEEN AYE AYES AND ZERO
KNOWS. ONE ITEM NUMBER ONE- AB
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY TWO WAS
THIRTEEN TO ZERO. MISTER CHOICE
BILL AB FIFTEEN NINETY SIX WAS
FOR AYE VOTES. ZERO NO VOTES. IN
THE REMAKE ENDED IN THE MEASURE
FAILED. MR COOPER'S BILL AB
TWENTY EIGHT NINETY FOUR WAS
THIRTEEN AYE VOTES IN ZERO NO
VOTES. THAT WAS FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIVE. FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX AB
TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY. BY MISTER
DALY THAT'S ME. TWELVE AYE VOTES
ZERO NO VOTES. I AM SEVEN AB
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY SEVEN BY MR
GARCIA ELEVEN I VOTES TWO NO
VOTES. FILE ITEM EIGHT BY MR
JONES SAWYER AB. TWENTY FORTY
THREE. PASSED WITH THIRTEEN AYE
AND ZERO NO VOTES. FILE ITEM TEN
BY MR RODRIGUEZ AB TWENTY SIX.
FOURTEEN PASSED WITH TWELVE AYE
VOTES IN ZERO NO VOTES. FILE
ITEM NUMBER NINE AB TWENTY THREE
TWENTY THREE BY MR LEVINE-
FAILED TO GET A SECOND ON THE
MOTION SO THERE WAS NO VOTE.
THAT CONCLUDES ALL THE VOTE
TOTALS FOR TODAY'S AGENDA.
SHADES FOR GREAT WORK BY THE
COMMITTEE STAFF AND WE ARE
ADJOURNED.